seven
seven that's two times in a row if this
was that game that you played the casino
i'm going to steal from rich it wouldn't
be good
you have to move the robber
i'm going to move the robber to the 11.
that's not ridge that's me yeah so then
you can only steal from hans oh
you're green
all right i'm gonna steal from home
don't do it to me yeah
what are you thinking paul you're so
lazy
there should be like a robot that we
could just talk and then it gets 10
hours of door dash day dude 10 hours of
door dash blue collar worker
you would consider it or dance blue
collar
no but
i bring a blue collar i brought i bring
a blue collar epic to the door dash
i wear boots and uh overalls while i do
it
you didn't know that you'd do that that
that was that mean that would blue
collar that's not doordash that's barn
doordash just like white it means like
being white and working
that's
all that
i worked at a gas station i got fired
but why why were you deciding because i
didn't check the bathroom before i left
one night apparently someone pooped in
there and overflowed it and i bought
seven saying he had to wash it he was
pissed
three taking a piss seven
three in a row
move that
card from hans
he tried to get away with it
we are looking for an intern that will
move the pieces for us if anyone's
looking to move the robber for us
we'll pay you in
um jokes no we'll pay you in sheep
we should get brad williams to be the
robber we can move around on the board a
lot of people wouldn't like being paid
in cheap like real [ __ ] but like they
wouldn't know what to do with them
but paul i'm going to take from you i
would know what to do like you got some
stuff
is everyone happy
oh i'm yeah just great does anyone have
any wood for brick i'm content like in
general or with right now in the setup
wait wait lighting you'll trade me a
brick yeah
for what you don't yes do it fantastic
cool cool you ever see that done before
that's a good trick oh that's great it's
like a damn silk road
sucks
that's an old reference
like 10 minutes are you wait
jesus are you representing the original
silk road or like the new no the old
silk road what what what's this other
silk
road you're so
country
there's another silk road
i was going to say it didn't seem like
that old reference to me but
i watched the whole time pirate roberts
and
why does it take wood to make roads
it's recycling old bits now
what no that's the first time we've
heard this what are you talking about
and it's not even that's my bit don't
take the time
that was a good thought don't worry we
can edit this all out this whole game
the first time i played you carlos man
see it he carl lessman see you
karma
i'm gonna start dreaming uh streaming uh
roller coaster tycoon 2 on twitch i hope
carlos mt is watching this
what'd you say yeah i can almost assure
you definitely no
did you ever play the lemonade tycoon
one that one was no i didn't
same [ __ ] but i played this tycoon
and which was your tycoon tycoon's
how does that go you're a private prison
owner you build a bunch of prisons
it's [ __ ] awesome
and i'm so good at it
they're like marijuana is illegal so is
interracial marriage
so i keep my boys in line
and i love you so you chose a male a
male prison
i actually my prisons uh women and
there's a bunch of trans prisoners in
the prison and they made everyone
pregnant
i started a colony i think so too
all right that's better wouldn't it if
he's sick to be in space prison like uh
riddick
from pitch black vin diesel
vin diesel yeah he's in space you gotta
you got a van that is a diesel
whose turn is it what's happening
uh creams is still uh setting up some
lighting right now so
ridges
american he's uh he's the highest of all
of us
i uh
whatever you'd like
are we still whispering hans
you know tim dillon's special goes live
at 2 a.m i don't know you better you
guys are yeah i'm going to give him some
[ __ ] i'm gonna go home and watch that
[ __ ] what's up awesome i love him yeah
timmy is the best do you think tim
dillon's just pretending to be gay
no i think you're just pretending to be
a country boy
no i don't think so
yeah me either actually
sorry uh
that would be a terrible bit though why
would i do that sheep
we like nines
six
i'll trade for a wheat
trade what for a wheat
a rock well i don't have any wheat so
this conversation ends here i'll trade
two rock for a wheat
two rock for a week
i trade two rock in a shape for a week
all right nobody's training yet i'm
gonna roll wait i'm gonna do the night i
don't know why i didn't do that
hans wow interesting choice
i mean
oh wait i'm not done
i just got what i needed
you can go
10.
for what
what do you want
i'll give you a sheep no
i'm okay i'll give you two sheep
no no thank you wait what do you want oh
wheat
i got no wheat all right wall
game's going probably nice save hans
what are you eating over there yeah vin
diesel hasn't been anything in a while
no i'm good two
oh someone's on there
paul paul
nice very nice oh
i went to the drive through panda
express asked if i could just have a
fortune cookie and they said no panda's
so far
uh you're plenty it seems rude
panda express
how old is the panda express
it seems like it just like popped up
right
sadness hopelessness that's how old it
is no that's what it expresses panda
express uh oh
discontent
ah cheer up do you know the oldest male
panda in captivity died like three weeks
ago really it was 32 nine wow
yeah
sad
the uh the staff forgot to bring their
lunches that day so they just shot in
the head
six chongqing zoo
zoo
probably pronouncing it wrong i have so
many sheets perfect you think i was a
sheep lord
chongqing
does anyone want any
i'll trade wood a wood for a wheat
two wood for a weight
how much wood
would a wood chuck yeah trade me two
wood and a brick for a week i got no
brick or two wood and
a sheep no you know what i don't need
any of that you know no
what do you think
all right
moving on
nine
there's a nine
let's go
and there's it
there's a nine
i'll take a shot of something
i'll come get it
why don't you take a shot of the vaccine
ridge
so you can get out of this
tell us how you really feel
mine yes i was just gonna get some water
nice that's a hot take paul i love that
well i'm so sad are you vaccinating
none of well they just announced that
the vaccine doesn't matter so none of my
vaccine material is going to work
anymore
dude they just said it
dude i didn't even get the polio back no
all the right-wing comedians i follow on
instagram were talking some [ __ ] the
past few days
like spencer dugal i don't even know who
the [ __ ] it is but all i read is if i
need the right wing talking points i
just go right to there's like two or
three comedians i just click on there
instagram
that's how i get all my news instagram
stories from them yes politically
extreme
open my comedians that i find
they're giving you all the correct
sources yeah this has to be right
i got some whiskey
i'm not going to drink any so
sorry here
that's wine
take any of these
i have some spices
i'm just gonna stay seated let's think
who the who who are the right-wing
people i follow instagram are you
following me um
you know alex jones used to have a radio
show here in austin i thought you're
gonna say a dick for a second and i was
like you cut it off dude he's a unit
he's a straight up unit he could be full
back
he
this stuff is fancy okay okay do you
don't mind yeah
i don't know can i drink this whole
thing
angels envy
are you just scrolling instagram there
uh
i was looking for a right wing um
you look at your message you're looking
at one right now sitting right next to
you that's what i said he follows me
i'm a libertarian
i don't like that lib isn't libertarian
so
i'm a vegan eco fashion
i will never be a libertarian i think
everybody should be forced to be vegan
at gunpoint no
no that is my whole lifestyle that's my
view well you're like actually like
you're vegan vegan yeah too let's say is
your girlfriend vegan yeah it's sick
because he gets sick
are you vegan because your girlfriend's
not vegan because uh are you whipped
vegan
when i lived in boston everyone was
uh liberal and i was like i'm going to
be vegan and so i i don't know
[ __ ] on you guys now literally i'm a
vegan republican how long have you been
vegan
i'm actually not i i've been like
cheating lately so
how does that make you feel cheese
so wait vegan vegan has
no dairy and no meat
yeah
and what's the other one where you can
have dairy
vegetarian okay my buddy he's vegetarian
but he eats enough ice cream i'm all
right with it
[Music]
he just he likes
cheers
i wish i could dermis too late i'd fall
asleep right away
yeah
seven
that is extremely good
our kansas you want more
no no
you guys remember that angel's envy
where it's the
it's like the middle eastern woman and
she's pointing at the u.s map and she's
like this one is kansas why is this one
not our kansas she's pointing back and
forth
it's like old vine why is it art kansas
yeah arkansas yeah
that's true
english got a lot of words like that
it's the natural state
so i guess they don't have fake titties
a main slogan taken from you main slogan
is the way life should be
it's for
of maine the way life should be yeah
wait go back to uh roller coaster no uh
roller coaster
yeah so
that was very interesting yeah there's a
video game called prison tycoon where
you're a prison award and you build a
prison
uh do you go out there and arrest a road
i know you're just taking all the
prisoners that are already arrested how
many of them did died
like how many have died in my first it
depends what type of prison i'm running
could you uh play football in your
prison like sometimes i could let them
do activities did you let them like so
they don't do a race war if you don't
let them do activities eventually they
race oh so your prison's diverse and has
a lot so like the the war would be like
whenever a normal rollercoaster tycoon
when they throw up when they get off of
a
now whatever it would be like when the
people are walking on a local second and
they hate all the rides so they just
start vandalizing your park
oh thank you hans you guys david
vandalize your park
yeah when they like hate because i
charged them ten dollars to go in the
bathroom and stuff
let's vandalize this place yeah
there's a game called prison tycoon yeah
yeah it's called american capitalism
sorry i left too loud in the morning is
a fun game
i like private prisons six i don't know
if you guys sold out
public prisons i'm a big private prison
guy
keep your prisons private no one wants
to see it is there anybody out there
like it's one of those viewpoints where
i feel like
you could just ignore the issue if
you're a politician but is there anyone
who's just outwardly like i love the
private prisons it's the best way to do
it yeah
if you want to have a society the best
way to do it is have people whose job it
is to
imprison people for and the more they
imprison the more the money they make
yeah why do they make money off that
though like
because it's like they run a hotel that
people can't leave
welcome to the hotel and so they can
just figure out we have vacancies and
they just fill it
up mm-hmm
yeah and they're mostly black
yeah in your prison or just in well it's
prison tycoon it's just the real world
so it's yeah
just comments
they have the the little characters have
races yeah they do and they have little
race wars is this like a [ __ ] skin
that someone made on top no it's like a
real game who made this it seems like i
think it was maxis and i think it like
it does to show you the terrible
parts of private prison so i think it's
supposed to like it's kind of a woke
game
i play i want to play sim ant on twitch
as well that's another favorite game of
mine sim ant
cement sim ant so when you play an ant
and you started drawing
yeah
oh i thought you were talking about like
you started colonies yeah just black
ants and then you fight the red ants
you're just like a human race back to
the race wars and sometimes there's a
spider that comes out when he [ __ ]
everybody's [ __ ] up or a lawnmower
did you watch that movie where there's
ants and it's a cartoon uh the woody
allen movie yes i did i love everywhere
bug's life
no there's ants
by woody allen
and there's bug's life
what's the difference well the woody
allen movie there's a there's a dorky
guy like there's a schindler's list and
then there's jurassic park
what's the difference
well in the woody album there's a dork
who
has sex with a really hot aunt
like uh that i you're confusing me if
these aunts like because they don't have
oh wait i don't need [ __ ] from anybody
is it an animal or a person
it's a woody allen version of an ant
i'm still confused i know i don't say
orange can't win i feel like they say
orange is losing i feel like you've
never watched annie hall
[Music]
woody allen he was in that toy story
movie right toy story
with that he was his he was the best
friends with the astronaut what did you
say you got a friend in me
who says i can't win
hans they're saying we're winning yeah
tons they're saying people
cons they're saying palestine in asia
you guys are you guys are you guys were
ripping hard so i was gonna make a trade
but i didn't sorry
a lot of chat that's not like that at
all nobody was watching
this is this just put the pressure on me
five five
we should play a drinking game while we
play this five is what king sounds
dangerously fun let's take one shot for
every chromosome that ridge has yeah
we'd be at 23.
you just called yourself [ __ ]
wait how many chromosomes is there
twenty-two all right let's build the
settlement that would be as the normal i
thought it was 23 and me yeah it's 23
and me so
is that was that the one only for that's
the one like that that's what my
girlfriend got isn't it 22 in me no i
think it's 23. 23. i've heard enough
hack bits on stage about it to know that
it's not i have no idea 23 i mean that's
like that
porn star
i have a fire ancestor.com joke i think
everyone does oh go ahead tell it thanks
so much now you're gonna say i have a
fire ancestry that's a weird brag like
the fire you do have very fiery answers
no the bits uh i was on
ancestry.com and it redirected me to
fbi.gov
and uh uh okay yeah and usually there's
crickets no it's one of those people oh
yeah you gotta be one of the bad guys in
300. no i was thinking like bond villain
but wow thank you oh both right that's
really nice xerxes you look good
the little fanboys that sucks his dick i
uh
three
the 300 of them
no no
you know they carry them around
four who were the 300 they were the
spartans and they were fighting the
palestines
they were fighting the persians and they
got the spartans got [ __ ] in their bus
when they were like young kids they did
that to the soldiers
okay
why did they do that what was the
purpose tough as hell i mean something's
gonna be tough
they might get some calluses
is that why you're so tough rich
[Laughter]
yeah you're really like a lot like a
spartan
i like the spartan mentality if i were
only a loincloth would they let me
perform at open mics oh of course you
could murder somebody they let you
that's true
four oh this is looking up
so guys i didn't know if you knew this
um
we listened to the fall out boy song
centuries
it's a great song yeah
did you listen to the the remix 100
[Laughter]
i
[Laughter]
so much just happened we're trading he
wasn't sure if he wanted to trade a
peanut fell out of his mouth
and then there was a loud there was a
loud unhooking noise it was like getting
off the ground
it's like a damn elephant
we're at the texas roadhouse
it was so crazy when i got to texas and
realized they had texas roadhouses here
that place is so good
really i went for the first time ever
recently and they're they're everywhere
you know that's right outback so
oh yeah
i uh trade wheat for something
anything
the besides a sheep
[Music]
okay rich's place is called the texas
load house
oh because we're loading cattle or what
texas toad house
um
longest chode who's got it
i wish i had a show dude my penis is
short and skinny
whatever whenever i have a sex well with
a woman i ask her if she likes a child
or a pencil
and if she likes a child then i fold my
dick in half and put it in
i didn't hear what you said but i don't
want you to feed it is that a street
joke in hershberg california
pennsylvania
so a cow walks into a bar and the
bartender says damn that's one hot ass
cow i'd like to [ __ ] that
would you rather have sex
i mean
cow's not bad
do you ever see that movie where the
donkey kicks circles
we're looking for an intern to move the
robber for us so if you live in the
greater
where are we
san antonio
we're in
austin area yeah i mean that's also kind
of nearby
i'm here with the great austin comics
rich hershberger paul cipher's kareem
yaga man
and hunt
and hans kim
kore wait cream are you living here in
austin i do i live here have we met
before
maybe
he does
once do you do my opinion occasionally
yeah
what do you do mostly
um
i was going to say butt stuff but i
don't want to give people the wrong idea
yeah 10.
somebody's going to take from you reg
please thank you
oh you got your old 10.
i am oh that worked out perfectly i feel
like
dude oh sorry you're good i'm going to
build a city
dude i [ __ ] up on my turn
way what happened rethink it
hash it out
let's go
all right this is you paul you look like
you're about to find a whiteboard and
solve an equation
i [ __ ] up my turned in this game's
annoying
there's always next turn maybe you did
place your house on a 2 and a 12.
i got a wheat strategy wheat
wheat
everyone has wheat except for green
you need wheat
uh
i'm okay
we're riffing
we're doing it so what do you think
about nancy pelosi going to taiwan
i was hoping they'd shoot down to china
is that where you were
oh that's funny
three thanks dude i'm like a john i'm
like jon stewart we sent the old lady
i could see that you look like him so
you're like i'm gonna pretend to support
china for no reason
yeah
red start trading for brick he says
does anyone out trade uh three
uh
wheat
nancy went to town
why three wheat for a rock
uh not with hans
ridge starts high and goes low most
people start the bidding low and then go
high but he's like one million dollars
the classic native americans trading
beads from manhattan
if they could see it today 12 beads well
i'll give you this whole island why did
nancy pelosi go to
because someone paid her a lot of money
oh all right well
good on her i like get that bag like a
bad [ __ ] secure in the
bag uh four
all right i'm building
i'm a builder making moves
so many fours
in austin
wait you talking
i don't need to put a
stone down oh my god you don't need a
stone for a settlement
you don't need your balls you're not
using them
speaking of balls should we update the
score how's that supposed to be
for the viewers at home yeah why not
speaking of nancy pelosi
what is that supposed to say right
what's the logical reasoning behind
calling me i built the settlement
i don't know you guys have sort of the
same frame
she has giant tits
yeah that's true karim how many do you
have five
yes
i'm a two red is at four four cream you
have five i've low-key did not see
orange that three stop pretending like
you speak the language of the youth
nine
i just like the nice i just want to fit
in man
what's the highest
seven
there's four numbers on this board i
can't count
wow you did that's good math that you
could count how many numbers
who wants wheat
i need brick
or rock
i'll give you rock for wheat okay thank
you oh i'll give you a rock
who wants wheat i'm accepting rock or
brick
rock or brick for wheat
barack i'll change your barack
what about wood for rock anyone want
wood
for rock
could anyone use a wood complete the
fifth
how do the ports work uh well
the original port was
taken over
okay i don't need the history of the
port i just need to know how it works no
but like the t you know
because i got a port now
you got
one
those that's a two for one on wheat so
every time i take wheat can i have some
water no
two wheat is worth any card so
yeah a little two for one
oh then i i'll trade for wheat
who wants to give me wheat
too late
oh i forgot to turn this to
shoot i'm doing a whole lot of stuff
right now i'll get the water later
this is such a bad thing waiting to
happen right now
cream that looks like a very expensive
mixer or whatever you call it a water
filter no the i'm stealing from you
oh i thought you picked it for a
handshake electronic interface oh yeah
it is the jews
luckily it's on the floor so right next
to the red water did that hit
that dead because i really really just
took a stone from me so
we're gonna throw it at you yeah
so what do you think about donald
trump's
mar-a-lago house getting raided that's
[ __ ]
why
he broke the law
dude
it's [ __ ]
oh man i think it's
i think it's dude i think we should
panty raid
are you really surprised that trump
broke the law
he didn't do nothing wrong the only
thing he was
wrong was he's the president he's
allowed to break the law
he's above the law well bill clinton
wasn't allowed to break the law
these are hot takes i love it well those
are my two favorite presidents todd
prefers bill clinton and
trump donald trump do you think people
voted for bill clinton and donald trump
what kind of person does that i
guarantee somebody a person who likes
criminals
i mean you probably do you had a goddamn
roller coaster prisoners
what if what if they like the first ride
they have uh for roller coasters they
just had a bunch of prisoners on it
they're like let's see
sounds like something trump would do
this uh
this game has really been a
rollercoaster hans what do you think
about it
i think that
11.
it's a good thing that it happened
you didn't break oh i think it's
probably a good thing because like
politicians get away with everything but
why are they singling out trump it's
because he didn't fall to the
establishment he didn't falter it's
because he he didn't follow the rules
represented the worst part of humanity
oh the comments are going off so once
it's about louis ck nice i like to raid
i wish i could read
but i'm blind alexander ocasio-cortez's
alexander butthole i'd like to do an fbi
cavity surge on that thing i like to do
an fbi cavity search of the empty spot
between your ears
when hans was a child
this man was trained personally by
tonight doesn't really hurt me when he
insults my intelligence tony his self
confidence in my intelligence but it
hurts me when he insults my you know
just overall manliness yeah
ability to
so what's your return
you have a retort
no retorts
how many cards do you have
do i have to legally you literally have
to tell me
are you gonna raid my house rolls if you
have less cards then yes
you have six how many cards do you have
kareem
did you roll seven or what are you
asking i don't know i rolled a knight
how many cards five
oh he's picking from us
of course
my strategy of not appearing to be a
threat is working
who wants wood
me i need
brick me too
do you have brick i don't know i brought
me a brick
no you want a rock not for you
i'll give you your rock back you want
yeah brick no i got rock you want give
me a wheat give me a weed and a stone
and you can have the brick
okay
and that's how you do it people so uh
who's this remind you of
nine
oh you just covered it up
bran tarth from game of thrones
i never i only read the book
oh
that wasn't what your
description of the book made you imagine
honestly i don't remember the character
from the book because the book's really
long confusing it's too many goddamn
characters he still hasn't finished them
books has he i finished i read the first
two
the first two
oh wait i'm um it's my turn
it's hard to riff and do and play uh is
any oh uh time for
we're always fighting with each other on
this
so why do you think that uh trump
kept classified documents it's kind of
weird
he probably just misplaced them
you didn't see he threw him in the
toilet didn't see the pictures of the
the cut up like letters what do you guys
think about uh new york post is real
joe biden's son hunter
i think he's oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that
ostrich farm that'll leave him smoking
crack yep
um who gives a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
that makes him relatable uh trade uh a
wheat for uh would
a wheat and a sheep for wood oh two
sheep and a wheat
two wheat
trade me two wheat two sheep for one
wood
i can't do it all right i can't do it
this game kind of interrupts the riffing
with the training
it's kind of like a new talk
after the podcast is over it's kind of
like a new topic every five minutes it's
the game's fault ridge that's what it is
um
six
what would be that why would he so i
actually don't know the full story what
happened
really
has a really biased opinion i actually
don't know what happened
it [ __ ] up what happened
what happened
no seriously tell me
you could you could sway my opinion
with what you tell me right now that's
[ __ ] sexy you won't sway my vote
though
i have a friend that works for the fbi
maybe i can call him that we can ask
what's his name
i don't think i should say
where does he live
i don't think he does anything cool for
the fbi i think i'm about to make a
pretty crazy move here but we're doing
it it works like the cafeteria
he just makes stir fry
three development cards that is
frightening i'm going this is a big move
what does chat think of this move you
could have built a city
yeah you know i'm gonna get a lot of
flack i think we should have a but uh
we built this
[Music]
we should have a wheel
oh
that's great three bricks thank you hans
oh wait i have two things on it so i get
two
correct
i'm the best dude
okay
you guys don't even tell me the rules
try to cheat i'm still
hans hasn't taken advantage of anybody
yet
i'm biting my time i'm riding the tall
grass
he asked for it
was consensual
we won't speak of the last game
i got nowhere to go i need to build two
roads
um
i don't think a five has been rolled
i'll tr i'll trade three sheep for a
wood
okay am i dude for a brick but
watch you be at like a port or something
too oh am i at a port no i'm not no
are you done
wait i'll trade uh
something
wait for a
brick or wood two wheat for a breaker
wood
you need a brick yeah i got you two
front right here
oh wait i thought you needed a break oh
you need a wood oh it was either yeah
i'm just trying to make a road sorry but
you're winning so i'm not going to trade
with you
that's
man i tell you
it's my problem with
yes
[Music]
you know these things they happen you
know
what are you losing
these things they happen but
all right i'm trading in four sheep for
a brick
ryan asks how do you play we'll show you
as cons
it's easy hans will send you a cameo of
how to play
oh my god
so you roll the dice and you pick up the
resources that your settlement is on two
if it's a city and you try to get ten
yeah
so
i'll trade you if i build can i build
one here yeah yeah because it's gotta be
two faces we have to put two two things
away yeah
oh what do you need
i need a brick
me too
whoa a little tag team action here
what
only one of you can win you know this
right what are you talking about only
one color will prevail it's like
medieval times i'm having so much fun
with my friends i feel like i've already
what's your favorite color oh that's a
loaded question
they just uh um kill tony just made a
night a tick tock
and i've been watching it and the one of
you was awesome
thanks man yeah yeah you're great and
you didn't tell us to even say that i
forgot you shouldn't have a ticket
anyone else paul it's a chinese security
risk you didn't even tell us to say that
can i have one please why i only have
three points i was trying to can i can i
have a card just four oh it's shane
gillis right with his your least
favorite your most annoying most
annoying race
yeah i died
um
what do you need heck did you keck
you didn't roll yet three no i used a
knight you traded before you rolled i
used a knight prior and i just rolled
the three which which really helps me
out if anybody's watching you are uh
hey mom you're a pro if you use the
knight before you roll kareem rolled at
three
now kareem has two settlements on a
three he's picking up
two wheat top kick
and pass the way
what do you think kareem what do you
need i'm okay for now rage good job
brother i appreciate you though man i
was willing to help out a friend this
game is pogrom so
pog champ
wait what does pog stand for actually
jesus
oh no god god peace of god peace with
all gods no that's peace
peace of god remember when pewdiepie
said that rachel's letter while he was
streaming and then
you know
now he's past 100 million subscribers
but nobody cares
oh
well when i did it outsourced they just
banned me wait here you go
i have a lot to give
to the world
to wheat for a brick to
[Music]
he's like i gotta trade with the brown
man
[ __ ] it has nothing to do with your
pigmentation
has nothing to do with you are great
hideous culture
oh dude come on new jersey's not not
that bad of a place
you could be from michigan
new jersey sucks dude
half our audience is from michigan from
new jersey yeah it's it's
ponz actually started in new jersey i
don't know if many people know that i
started from new jersey
had a bit of a nerd
i'll trade uh come on what else
rock had a bit of
a had a bit of a terzi
i don't used to scrub toilets at stress
factory back in the day jersey mersey
nerdsy lurzy turzy coursey nursey bersie
shirt vinnie brand is a piece of [ __ ]
brick no
i'd fight vinnie brand wait is that what
yeah does he own both stress factories
or just the connecticut
there's the connecticut strawberry yeah
no
also i've never met vinnie brand or
worked with him so i'm sure he's a hey
it's vinnie brand hey
what are you doing i'm trying to make
people laugh hey get the [ __ ] out of
here chicken bomb
doesn't he don't oh he plays like a
compilation of comedy movies before you
go on stage right i love when commute
comedy clubs do that so it's like it's
like really hyped you up
yeah you could have just stayed at home
and watched this on tape it's like and
it's like the best comedy movies of all
time it's like
anyways here's hans kim
it's like a [ __ ]
five-minute sketch improv troupe from
the local area
here's why you shouldn't use your phone
during the show
do you guys want to and i'm a tree you
guys want to make an improv troupe but
when we go to improv shows we'll just
sit in the front row and one by one
perform our stand up act
trick them and just get books
nine trick people into hearing our jokes
yeah we're a cool improv group and we
just do our same five minutes and
everything so i'm on guard
and i've heard this bit before at the
creek
did somebody find i need a diet vegan
and an octopus
exterminator oh does someone say vegan
exterminator
we'll we'll cook the book so it goes in
our favor
ridge
he's coming
what are you doing bridge is a master of
improv
did you go to second city ridge
who is that that's a knock
you mean
yeah rich
is it sullivan put your hands to
domino's we're about to get swatted did
somebody order us pizza
whose turn is it
it could be i think it's technically
mine
eight
what was the number did you get did you
guys pick it up hey guys what's up dude
in the middle of the podcast we're
recording it do you have a microphone
come on in not on me
why not
anyone have a microphone on them
what number is it now we have
nine would you mind 609
yeah
so here and now what is it what was it a
nine and now it's an eight you rolled an
eight right
yeah uh two eights
that's uh
now we have two tv credits on the
podcast let's go
this is because i was on the local news
when i got expelled for bringing a knife
to school
how big was the knife
no i went to a vocational school they
don't care what the [ __ ] you did
what'd you graduate with
what do you mean
that's my gpa
hi i'm kareem like uh engineer nice to
meet you brother uh
programming and web design i have 40
cards so i'm going to make a move now
you gave me a guy diploma nope no i
didn't what are you talking about gave
me the dice are you sure yeah or else
why would i have them dude i was going
to make back at the table pull it up on
your phone seriously
racism it's nine every i think the dice
are broken
it's been nine every time i prefer
contrived contrived racism
is that a word just making up words
prison tycoons
have you ever heard a video in prison
tycoon yeah it's awesome
do you get to like pick the rapes
no you try to reduce the amount i mean
depending on what type of award you're
driving you're trying to win the game
less rapes what was your uh main product
you uh produced
other license plates license plates for
what state was it
i never got into it
it's so stupid
and sometimes you can send them to fight
fires too
wait they were firefighters prisoners
are firefighters they use them for
wildfires
do you notice
what makes them so wild that liberal
hell hole i agree
yeah the most populous state in the
country i don't know why
it's because it's the best
you think i don't know
i don't know which state is better than
california alabama
people texas does not have the movies
six
i had a friend needs to do stand up
and he got to like open for dane cook
and then he moved to boston and just
been an open micro for like eight years
and i was like dude just move back to
hawaii are you done
everyone's moving to like the more
popular states for stand-up go somewhere
where nobody else is yeah
and just be a winner in
south dakota and just get paid four
grand to
feature for jim gaffigan
dylan are we always on screen can you
move the robert to the three
you're not talking
thanks and then can i have one of your
cards please
[ __ ] i should have done something on my
turn can i do something
right
it seems like a conversation
what a good observation by me repeated
what was just rolled it must be a
television
a six was rolled okay i missed like
three of my nines but i'm not gonna pick
them up i'm gonna build three roads
what is that that was all the wood i
traded to you
who makes us i was listening to joe
rogan today they were talking about as
sad as some stand-ups like give up stand
up when they become writers and i was
just like i would give up stand up so
fast
if somebody would pay me to your right
yes
i did door dash for 11 hours i will pay
you to quit
i would write for big bang theory for a
heartbeat how much
writers get paid a lot don't they
yeah but you need to know how to read
and write before you do that right
i'm just the ideas man
i'm that guy that just sits rich just
passes in like stick figures you're
doing the big snake
i just do the the old hangman thing you
know
pretty good at drawing that
where's that licker at
let's get another shot
yeah please hell yeah here you go hans
thank you
you're welcome hans would you like a
sean too
i'm from east coast originally but i
moved out to austin uh not too long ago
six yep
it's great man me and hans are like best
friends now right hans
he's a big advocate for me and
uh
do you guys ever have those people
growing up that were like uh
black
no i never had them um
i don't know
yeah we had one black person went to our
school what was his name
deontay he murdered somebody
supposedly
yeah he's still in jail
they're trying to give him the death
penalty um
this guy talked about
christ hans do you fact check these
people before you have them on your
podcast
i'll take break well you know there's a
lot of societal issues that go along
with it so i don't really blame you
don't want
you don't want brick
i want brick you have rock
i have chris rock yeah you have wood
i got rock thanks
i've completely lost i've lost my
strategy what else can you throw in to
sweeten the deal
all right i'll do it
see that's how you do business rich
that's how you do it you were you were
fascinated by arkansas i remember
you're right but it doesn't matter it's
alcohol it takes all the germs out okay
that's right bridge is fascinated by
arkansas this is the most futuristic
place i've ever been dude i like arsenal
i like arkansas reminds me of
pennsylvania
just a little bit
what are you talking about
i'll be selling out arkansas
cheers to the best damn comedy scene in
the land yes chicago
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
i can't drink on camera my parole
officer will see it really yeah
wait what are you what did you go to
jail for
i can't talk i've murdered somebody in
my hometown it's still acting and then
it became trans racial deante's
you're his accountant oh [ __ ] should i
have not have said his whole name
what's his name you shouldn't have
talked about it at all
i kind of regret that
you should have stopped before you said
there was one black person if i'm down
what do you want me to lie okay thanks
i'm good thank you wait i'm still going
maybe later i didn't go yet thanks hans
i didn't go anywhere
oh jesus christ yes you did
did i roll and i saw you put your hand
down
north campus nice are you gonna be near
me are you gonna have a studio
you can come over and hang out at my
pool if you want
what's the address
you can't come over here
yeah
are we living with this song yeah
hey
do they play katan
i don't know who that is
derek uh
oh
i thought i had the headphones on i said
sam lundqvist for some reason lundqvist
i was like that sounds like a pretty
funny person yeah i know i know
a swedish hockey player for the penguins
we were talking about hockey earlier you
said lundqvist where am i live patrick
lundqvist is his name
who's that
did you roll
is this your role yeah
yeah i don't even know how to play this
game when i'm getting pissed off
you play katan
yeah yeah
we're gonna kick paul out that's what
we're doing next round what the [ __ ]
this is a democracy i was already
planning on leaving but now i don't want
you guys to feel like i'm letting you
kick me out
all right why are we planning on leaving
because it's late i'm tired
oh yeah i love this game
yeah he would say i'm hans fierce's
competition yeah we played two games
why would you build a road through there
dude i won one game
and now this is the second game
who cut off paul like that that's really
rude i don't even know how to play paul
you can still build wait i have longest
road i just realized right now i can
build i can build a
settlement in between
yeah all right how sick are these 3d
pieces
i can't wait till i
people like me and send me [ __ ] dude
that'll never happen like you don't you
don't think so i don't know what
what would you do what's the favorite
thing you've got i think anthrax is
coming back probably
private jet flights
um i think you're gonna say private
parts is this from a box that you can
get no look at the background
printer someone made it it's mm wow
look at our robber dude look at that
this is beautiful yeah
that that guy that the tv show what's
his name the blonde i think he said he's
a 3d printer right yeah i was like
yeah
that's [ __ ] cool you never got that
from this is [ __ ] great yeah thanks
man
i don't know who you are i hope you're
watching people just said you [ __ ]
randomly they won't even matter
what was the coolest thing you ever got
up all night
what was the coolest thing you got sent
to you from up all night
a dick
gay sex
is anyone up top
do you ever get posted on there's
anyoneup.com back in the day yeah yeah
hey you lost your longest road dude that
is so weird
was he allowed to build there yeah [ __ ]
when you were younger i knew about 11
party i was unfortunate when i was like
nine you didn't think
about that
you can get four chances
i'm letting these people down and
express all right
can you give us our stuff back
what's going on we need the robber
how am i drunk after tv don't you get
that
hold on to that if it makes you feel
safe no it doesn't count it doesn't help
me this is four three percent
who has the longest round
nobody i had it and then paul just
[ __ ] built a home right now he said
[Music]
don't you remember when i sent that role
to you if you put it in the restaurant
i was playing with my friends they were
new to playing
and they're like you can build a
settlement yeah between tourism no you
can't and then we looked it up and you
could yeah
oh my god you played like 50 games
without that
i would have changed everything yeah it
does change a lot
i mean right in this game it already has
yeah
that actually really helps paul are you
done yeah you should you know what you
should do paul you should change your
name to song
of the math from damascus yeah yeah i
know me and you are big religious guys
i'm uh quite really 11.
are you pretty religious oh yeah
definitely
the most you like go to church right
yeah yeah whoa that's so religious you
guys are asking what my favorite you're
like asking your favorite songs mine is
oh holy night
really yeah yeah and i was listening to
uh mary did you know earlier
a very well written song oh holy night
or mary did you know yeah i listened to
fiddler on the roof that doesn't make me
religious right
i
i've never heard of fiddler on the roof
is that about david
no it's like a it's about a jews trying
to marry their daughters off
that's what it's about are you done are
you being serious they're four daughters
yeah wait they their daughters are
[ __ ]
ah no
my daughter's a [ __ ] what do they have
what am i supposed to do i need to get a
fiddle and get on a roof my daughter's a
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
it's just it's one of those those those
i was it's a recorder it's not even a
fiddle it's a five
i was going to say is this like one of
those word play things like a fiddle i
was in the theater on the roof i was in
guys and dolls i was in the music man i
was in the whiz an all brazilian version
of the whis and you wonder why we bully
you
you know but my whole hometown is i was
one of the all the white people were the
flying monkeys in that that one
they made us all they made a skateboard
and be flying monkeys
would be so cool we did like kick flips
on stage and stuff
yeah where did you live
in marlboro massachusetts it's just like
a huge it's like half brazilian though
population
i don't know just brazilian a couple of
did you say
we're successful and then everybody else
is like let's move to this yeah because
it seems like brazil pretty far from
massachusetts yeah well there's
connecticut like that too
no
it just happened to be a place that had
a couple families
yeah
because it was lit yeah
you want to do it again
did people
[Applause]
[Laughter]
they put mayonnaise on their pizza
that's a big brazilian thing wow yeah
they're uneducated really yeah
shout out in the comments have you heard
of brazilians putting man did you do
brazilian jiu jitsu no i should have
though and there was a lot of it going
on really yeah i thought it was karate
but it's ground karate
yeah brazilian is like a lot of like
grappling yeah i appreciate the feedback
i would have been good at wrestling
i wrestled for 12 years i mean haunted
russell before yeah he beat me
no i did that
really it was a tie yeah nothing
happened yeah what belt you quit
i wrote
[Laughter]
listen everybody's a little gay
wrestling
i remember wrestling through
yeah teddy graham uh
give him the mic
and i was uh i was a heavyweight
i was yeah yeah no i was a heavyweight
so you've always been but i it was
mostly fat so i would just i would
because i'd have to be in the
heavyweight category so i just get
[ __ ] smoked every time by these
[ __ ] testosterone out
[ __ ] 13 year olds with like angry
dads and they just smoke me and then i'd
see their dad with a mustache with a
veins off popping out of their head damn
like don fry but it made me stronger
maybe learn how to be submissive
you know taught me to enjoy it down
there pinned down between a man's butt
cheeks
embrace it somebody getting your ass
kicked you know dude that south park
episode where they all sign up for
wrestling because they like protesting
real rap it's so good
for volleyball and i didn't make it you
guys aren't going to want to play
another game after this right yeah okay
oh yeah paul is going to leave yeah i am
unless unless he changes his mind
i'll trade you to uh bullies me
i don't want to make trades over the
phone
wait
would now
tell them i said no thank you
well
wheat
what you trying to trade two wood for
one wheat
well i don't have it
i don't have it
i ruined that sorry guys
it's my bad
i technically have seven but i mean oh
because you have longest road yeah it's
how does it take to win
ten
ten
how about doing good
what's wrong
there's no yawning in katan
yeah what is this yatan sorry i know
it's this game's got a lot of action
[Laughter]
dude we're settling right now hard
all right i'll say for saul i've been
playing diablo immortal on my phone
shouts out if anyone in the comments
wants to play the album yeah we've been
playing guitar oh dude katana on the
phone is just wait is it katana or katan
that's the old days
argument right
that's the that's the oldest argument
four
god
dude what the [ __ ]
well
or what
did you do a mic tonight
yeah i did a [ __ ] show
oh wow cool man huh
sorry i'm on camera i'm a little more of
an [ __ ]
just a little more conversation
i did a couple shows and then i'm like i
did a couple yep
i did creek
i did creek and then
largest army
and then did your feet get wet
almost at green jay
can you move it to ten hans and i went
up because i needed to come back
yeah and i just thanks my ass off
bridge can i take from you
and then i went to banana mike and said
some things i shouldn't you just give me
any card i trusted it
banana mark it was
yeah oh i can just give you anything you
can just give me a card because when
people say things mean to me on stage i
get really defensive and then i say mean
things back and then i realized they
were just joking and now i'm not
it's a [ __ ] trick
did you guys do
nothing we suck
why didn't you go out
i got done with doordash five minutes
before i came i just rode all night i
had to do doordash because uh
i mean you could just use your
just learn how to do some things
five you think she was gonna kick you
out
it's
so bad
that's so sad
yeah what's your venmo
i don't ask for money
i'm not a
trans poc i don't know no one wants your
wood
wahans
uh i need brick
anyone a brick
for what
stone wood
give me sheep and a stone i don't have a
stone give me a stone i don't have a
stone
you want a sheep for a a brick
a wood and a sheep for a brick
what about
oh
why don't have you ever thought about
doing a live show at the creek where you
just played katan with three other
comedians homes
no i've never thought about that
is that it's in the works i think we're
getting wait wait wait
what are you gonna give me a brick a
sheep and a wood that's a good idea
and michael che for breakfast because
that's our lesson it doesn't help it
doesn't help
it doesn't help
cause he is still performing he's your
dream katan group to play with hans kim
what about rock do you have rock for me
it's uh
wood i want rock what the [ __ ] is the
chess guy's name what oh you went wrong
[Laughter]
i really i think we better just let that
go i'm not talking to you guys sorry
just talking about hello let me google
crazy racist chess guy and see if it
comes up
oh gary kasparov no
bobby fischer
it did come up when i searched crazy
racist chess guy
there's always one what was wrong six
yeah
shout outs to bobby fisher
for real
i'll try to wait for
[Music]
a rock
karima's nine points i triggered wheat
for a rock
another one
another one i can't do that
i'll wait for a wood i'm gonna make the
classic move to wheat for wood okay
i would have done it for one but you
already offered two
yeah so i can't go back on that eh
yeah you can i'm gonna get french fries
on him even though i'm gonna fall asleep
directly after i arrive at home
you guys know that move where it's not
worth it at all and then you can't sleep
yeah but just the idea of it
knowing that you could
that you could give yourself happiness
through your mouth yeah
and suspend
the little bit of time i have before i
have to wake up tomorrow morning and
face this reality all over again
hans remember we did a catan night in
the snow ice storm and we all
drove to your house still and played
yeah
and you're like why did you guys come
here you don't have sheep
oh yeah that was dangerous wait i gotta
roll how long have you been playing
hans we we go we've been separate
december yeah i'll do something since
december yeah five
han saw me at creek and he's like dude i
think you're like one of the funniest
people i've ever seen live and i was
like oh thanks man
and then he's like let's play katan
he was like did you see my set i was
like no i didn't think i was taking a
[ __ ] yeah he was like oh han's like no i
was taking a [ __ ] and it sounded better
yeah
are you done that's bad that's a rite of
passage i feel like
yeah
kareem i can't really poop outside of my
own home
i don't know if anyone else has that
problem
i'm gonna play this monopoly card does
anyone have any stone if you do you have
to give it to me no i don't have any
stuff i have any stone i have to give it
to you yeah hans you have 40 cards i
don't have any stone let me see right
now yo legit 10 uh seven hasn't been
rolled in wait no way there's only one
stone when there's
i have one card
hold on that was really dumb whenever uh
dude the irs is watching this you've had
your wasted you've been operating now
russell what a three you don't have any
stone i don't have any stone dude
show right now you have 30 cards i don't
have any stones guys like to play a
monopoly
is he cheating
i'm a thimble
everyone likes the thin ball that's the
most popular one 10. what's the thimble
dude dang cook's monopoly bit is
incredible
yeah
hey uh kareem i have stone hans is
[ __ ] me right now i know he has stone
i'm gonna listen no i have stone now but
you played it too early
yeah why did you play it before you
rolled i just got ten you might as well
roll and then oh i think you're gonna
play prior anyways does anyone have
sheep how about that yeah yeah yeah yeah
you missed out on three rocks
you're winning you're not nine points
we're not doing that [ __ ] you want to go
you guys are kidding right no we're not
kidding play the game all right two
roads
anyways
she gave me sheep
all right hans you're up put the roads
down
you cheater
yeah we'll help you
okay
six what do i have to do
[Laughter]
long yawn what do i have to do
everyone wants to do yes
for nothing can you just give me one for
free
i'll take a sheep
can you let me
not to spare
why is one sheep so much bigger than all
the other ones in the picture
is it a perspective thing is he closer
to the camera
yeah he's closer to the camera you do
this
put it on kareem
i know i'm gonna even put it on myself
because
i don't want him getting
rock that bad jesus would be proud wow
that's [ __ ]
up
and it's not a rock
houston it is not a rock
it is afghanistan can i plug my podcast
before i leave
what's your podcast it's called the
tinfoil hat podcast with sam tripoli i
was introducing sam tripoli and i
accidentally said tim
tim tripley
three sheep for
wheat three sheep then he went up on
stations like give it up for ellie wong
oh damn you got your ass
that's funny
uh
three sheep for
a rock or a wheat
nope
nope
what is your roll ridge
six
eight
eight
who wants to trade me you should be
happy i got you sheep
nope
except that anyone want to trade me
sheep i have sheep sheep what do you
want
okay give me two sheep for one week
why because i only have two
all right give me a sheep and something
else for a week
why
i'm losing
ah
okay sheep and wood all right deal
okay now i'm gonna
build
something it's never too late
what are you listening to oh just
[ __ ] raise burning
who
uh
jeffrey berner
raymond cabrera you're in a band yeah
in a band we made an album with liz
flatt today
whose recording equipment did you use
raymond cabrera he's the rick rubin of
the group
and honestly
it's pretty bad
at least you're honest but it's funny so
it's great
it's bad but it's fun as [ __ ] and some
of them are funny
comedy improv music
available those are three things that i
just wish i didn't have in my life
anymore hans can you well we got some
dope [ __ ] dude
can you put it on me and uh simon nash
are
making a flight of the concord desk no
the other three though
live yeah we have two songs so far uh
the first one is called the beast has
monkey pox which is about the beast from
x-men getting monkey box
and then the second one is uh
about
it's a song that he already had written
about him being the coolest middle
schooler
hans you're up thanks kareem you're
welcome hans
and we're called paul simon
oh i have
i had the long wait how many oh he has
four over there how many of you yeah how
many night cards do you have
four yeah
well what the [ __ ]
are you kidding me
wait this is a first release
a lot of our songs
i'll trade you
two wheat for a rock
to wait for a rock
was on our album today
liz splatt was on our album today and uh
let me just like
let me just i mean hitting that vape was
probably the best one but
it's very low energy wrap yeah
six
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
i wish the main vocals were as energetic
as the backup vocals
you're talking about me dude
you're talking about me you've never
seen the cartoon hey
you want something energetic from the
album that we produced and released
today
three
you don't shoes this
young's flat with the [ __ ]
you know me [ __ ]
i'm from the 2-6 [ __ ]
i'm not from there
but i got cool hair
i just changed it up
put it in my sippy cup
call me baby [ __ ]
i run the [ __ ]
yeah that's pretty good
that was a taste of
apple wallet
now i'll show you great pogs of fire
wells
[Music]
[Music]
it sounds like a like a run the jewels
b-side like i didn't
[Music]
all right i really want to leave
oh yeah did you post them where'd you
post them where can you find them we're
we're on band camp
that's where you can find it first but
it's uh
always
everywhere else
this is called hitting that vape
by the way i call your man that vape
[Music]
[Laughter]
can you help me take longest road so
that kareem doesn't win
what do you need brick and wood i got
wood
you want sheep
yep give me all your wood
you have
uh brick no
why not
i don't know dude if i had brick i'd
give it to you can i have another sheet
for that
sure uh no
uh do you have ah he's gonna pull this
yeah you want wood he's gonna he's going
for longest road and then he's he's
going for the night card
i just did another really paul you're
never leaving i just did another really
dumb strain
that was a dumpster i'm gonna watch tim
dillon's new spell no you're gonna
tim dillon oh he's um at 2am it's gonna
be on netflix oh really yeah
did he get on netflix yeah i get longest
road [ __ ]
downplaying it on his podcast though so
it might not be good
he's been like don't expect much
why did he say not just to expect this i
don't know he just hasn't even promoted
at all he go to twitter he hasn't even
like
and it comes out tonight yeah
like 30 minutes he doesn't seem to be
very concerned about it at all
it's one of those specials you don't
promote it's like a
secret release why do you think it's not
gonna be good it seems like he's a great
stand-up i don't have no idea why he i
mean paul said he was downplaying it on
a special on his podcast yeah he's just
been like telling her telling everyone
to
temper their expectations 11
11. so good for hans
wait hans do you have nine or ten reds
i have nine i have nine reds don't i no
you sure yeah
i was looking at videos of quicksand
yesterday and every single youtube
comment section has references through
john melanie's quicksand joke and it's
so funny which ones
it's like uh
when i was five i thought quicksand was
going to be a much bigger deal than it
was
yeah
yeah
hey paul if you're in the game
sooner
oh cream i'll trade with you now
yeah let's end this go [ __ ] yourself
sheep my people are ready to be taken
over by a different i i'd like a sheep
hans i have nine no
yeah that was silly
you've done scorpion tailed it
is there a way to commit suicide in this
game
it's that small door it's there's a
little sign on it here hans you can go
i let a lot of people down everyone
thought green was gonna win
seven
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven [ __ ]
don't stare at another person's phone
rich that's so rude
that's such a rude thing to do to
somebody paul just got a text message
from a number that he doesn't have saved
so whoever that was yeah it says new
order go to whataburger
is that still open this is what replaces
your loved ones yeah whataburger's
always open wait 24 hours really these
these are the checks that we're just
talking about it's always open
it's all my door to text
poor guy the only person that texts me
is door dash
just telling me to do things and not
saying please
i'm stealing from you paul's actually
doing really good
shut the [ __ ] up that's rich
yeah you have seven let me steal from
you rachel yeah steal from ridge
what the hell was that
are these good
i wanna try one okay what is that does
that hurt i think it's like a zen thing
right yeah oh oh those are eight that's
a lot of milligrams can you spoof them
you can poof anything
you guys see the new pokemon it's a fido
it's a dog made out of bread
it's awesome really yeah
pokemon rules is he coming gluten-free i
don't know maybe
wait so whataburger's really open still
like my burger's 24 hours oh it is oh
that's fantastic every whataburger is 24
hours oh really i've i've never had one
of our literally too i'm not saying that
for clout
they have good friends it's better than
in and out
no i don't what do you think constantly
that is way better
whataburger is trash what the [ __ ] void
announced
in and out five guys wendy's rv's burger
king nothing beats a soda in a styrofoam
cup whataburger gives you styrofoam it's
like lean yeah it's like sip and lean
yeah what do you know about sipping lean
you know i'll sip lean what's lane i
listen rap music it's what blacks do
oh
your turn paul
[Laughter]
what's your music group called it's
called race six race burning yeah razor
burning he has talk [ __ ] about rick
rubin all the time yeah and then
we always do some sort of apology song
to work for him
because we're one of them
like the first couple tracks to be like
[ __ ] you stupid scumbag you haven't
[Music]
don't you see we want to be like you
[Laughter]
oh
this game was so close to being over and
then hans just had to
himself into it that end
he done scorpion tailed it
he tried to sandwich paul
uh
i don't know
canon
canon vixia gf
nice camera
build the city who does hans can you
change that eight to city please thank
you
thank you hans what happened
i got a nice camera spent a bunch of
money on it and i'm trying to use it
more
what are you gonna film
well i've been doing some podcasts but
are you done would you like to do a
nightly podcast
[Laughter]
you lost me at nightly
so sure about that
you could have been like i'll pay you
100 000 no
just no
who wants rock me
i need wheat
i'll give you wait thanks i'll give you
one thanks
i didn't even have weirdos just bluffing
together
powers are tired of not using the mic
anymore
two four six seven
eight nine hanza's at nine all right
you can't we're almost done we have two
viewers on three
we can't let them down
no it's not the same
yeah even we have two people watching to
see what happens
who are they
those are just the viewers awake right
now there's gonna be so many [ __ ] me in
there think about this
later
vampire freaks.com tell them to follow
me all right paul you're up
paul
me and my girlfriend sign up for the
field app anybody else on the field app
here
five
what's your feel bad yeah it's that for
couples to find people to have sex with
i don't think we're actually going to
sign up for it
just to see the landscape yeah i know
i know that's the kind of do you find
other couples it's like a third right
like you'd find
but do like hand stuff at the movies so
you're gonna play the field
uh
yeah so i want to go on there and see
what the deal is uh i think ben brazil
was on there
as a bull
nice as they say
it's like in the cup situation it's like
the antique oh the one who [ __ ] you
yeah
it's like the antithesis of a cuck
are you done wait anticipate hold on hi
that was a cool word no nine i have to
pick up
whoa oh wait until this is a cool word
can we all just
recognize how cool the word
entertainment is the antiquities like is
that the protagonist this is the guy
who's [ __ ] the opposite wife that's
the opposite this is new to me these
guys say i can barely read it
dude just said he wants one of you to
bone his girlfriend
[Laughter]
you want one of us to [ __ ] your
girlfriend no why is your leg shaking so
much it makes me think that you're going
to win this round we're going to find
like a a
femme dog i'm building two roads
[ __ ] the [ __ ] because then i'll be
more secure about it yeah what are you
gonna build two roads for what's the
point
yeah
then she could just leave me for a woman
too
so why am i what what you know what i
mean you guys are lots of winnings
yeah
you still have eight roads
how many do you how do you have yeah i
know
yeah yes i can get 10.
you have to get a little jealous of the
funniest thing about three times
you didn't see that coming home did you
get a person how did you just go back to
being like do you just want to eat
spaghetti
really
like after you've come and stuff it's
just like
how do you just go back to normal couple
stuff just like have you had it
oh no i have not hans just
just kidding won don't know eight
yeah wait what did you put down
oh yeah it's just like i guess you want
to go see a movie
this is
weird
hey do you guys go to alamo draft house
yeah that place is awesome it's great
yeah we have a mini theater in our uh
complex too it's like a big
tv with leather seats and you can like
what like rent it out or something no
you just go down and use it and if you
have a laptop you can just play whatever
off netflix and i want to do like movie
nights and watch like i want to watch
louie's new movie down there oh fourth
of july yeah
that'd be
i think this thing is
you should try to get david lucas to
come play guitar i don't think he would
like it very much
all right guys
check it out
man you played more trees than a puerto
rican
that's it i think i won
dude he posted a really funny heckler
clip on youtube like the past few days i
watched this morning that's it there's
like a 14 minutes
but that would have taken a round
i was i was kept by when did you get
victory point did you get the last one i
got one right done i got one right at
the beginning i'm just gonna hold on and
then i was buying for the night and then
i got a victory point and then i bought
a knight and then i got victory point
hannah night
so you just bought that on this turn yes
this is what i got this you got three
victory points
good job ridge i got second
paul got lost
i mean
if you're not first you're last so we
all tied for no i'm second okay
you want to play out second place no
i got it bridge do you want yeah no rage
one
what'd you win
victory points oh
i was going for the largest army but i
couldn't it kept getting victory points
instead
you had it on the next turn i did
anyways rich can i get out on work
yes
all right well thank you for having me
frightening taking off the headphones
now that i know how to play it thanks
for watching strategy yeah yeah i'm
gonna go on reddit
the catan read it yeah that's how i
learned how to do everything that's
learned how i learned how to [ __ ]
picture damn ready
what they did
or you're playing games here right yes
all right in the moment
i'm gonna go get some tobacco
when he says let's just smoke on camera
when he says tobacco
we have technical difficulty
you don't smoke on camera
this will work i don't wanna you just
can't
monetize it can you
yeah we
can just say what california
you don't want to smoke
yeah we're in california right yeah
yeah
california
you took it away from me that's how long
the game extended the game i gave myself
a fighting chance
and that's what you really asked for
the numbers just didn't get rolled
so rage what do you think about this
setup it's pretty elaborate
this is very elaborate i like setting
around on the couches
it's way better than last time right
yeah we sat off the table and the table
it gets your
your back gets sore
yeah and it's hard on your butt
oh yeah so you so you're moving soon
yeah
nice
is it gonna be nice to be closer to
downtown which is gonna be
it's gonna make this stuff easier that's
true this is pretty far
yeah
it's only like 16 minutes
from downtown yeah but this other house
is going to be so much closer
you got the
got the tobacco
the wacky tabaki
there's some wacky right there
yeah there it is
yeah it's right here
it's already
loaded what are you smoking them
i like wheat
no like the little packs that you have
oh i quit cigarettes so i do nicotine
pouches
are you patching yourself that's eight
milligrams that's intense yeah zen only
go up to six well i've been smoking
since i was like 15. oh my god really
wait when did you stop
like three four months ago oh okay
how terrible was like the first week
pretty bad well it lined up i got
covered
so that you're like this is a good
excuse to quit yeah no it was like
honestly a good uh
time to do it because with the smoking
felt terrible the withdrawals are bad
for nicotine
it like hurts your well that's the only
thing i've ever withdrawed from
nicotine
but it's like wait why am i so antsy
right now and pissed
do we want to take another a gentleman
shot before we start this thing oh yeah
let's take a rip too
what makes it a gentleman shot
i don't know i guess it's just we're all
guys
it over there yes i do
would you like this sir can you hear me
yeah i can hear you
yes please
this is a paul's water bottle water so
you can have that
i'm all right
oh dude i need to get one of those
where'd you get that from that one looks
updated
amazon
you can hear you pumping in the mic it's
satisfying i could bump you up
are those like zens
yeah well
they're similar yeah like same yeah do
you want one how many do you go through
at a time like it you go through like
one pack a day
uh
probably a little less but close because
yeah yeah
the zens have
it's really easy to go through them
they're so small oh yeah and you can
have them anywhere movies
you know yeah you don't have to spit in
a bottle
on stage sometimes i'll have a zen
passion
or one of these
beyond
i think those are cheaper you think
patches are healthier than smoking it
because it doesn't have chemicals
definitely yeah like not inhaling yeah
but it takes more of it it doesn't hit
you all at once you don't get that slow
release it's not as much but like i did
patches once i tried to get off it
and it was uh it was still like by the
end of it i was like craving patches
you know i was craving the feeling of
like a sticky on my arm
[Laughter]
a sticker that puts good juice good
chemicals into your skin yeah and that's
also pretty freaky that like you can get
drugs into your system
by a sticker
yeah there was a guy that said he got
drugged in europe because someone stuck
a syringe in him
well that's a little more than a sticker
well have you seen uh
have you seen thank you for smoking yeah
that scene at the end where they they
kidnapped him and put like a million
patches on him so he overdoses
yeah
is that a true story nicotine overdose
doubt jason reitman though
the joker
or the riddler or the two-face in batman
no the director who directed
no like the guy who was the who's
two-faced
jack nicholson no
oh yeah that guy that guy but that's not
yeah harvey dunn's character
i don't know his name
but the jason reitman is the guy who
direct that booty with him in it
also
was for the first time i did roast
battle he was one of the judges
who was
jason reitman the guy directed thank you
for smoking wow
yeah he's a comedy fan yeah he's a big
comedy fan was it the roast battle in
austin or in l.a yeah in la he he
stopped by
they rose battle used to have like
celebrity
guests like almost every every week
it was hosted by brian moses too right
yeah i think it still is and it was in
the original room no the belly room
belly room yeah i used to listen to that
podcast oh yeah rest battle podcast yeah
like four years ago
it was a good one were you on there at
that time yeah damn i might have
listened to you that's crazy i only did
one roast when i was out in austin but i
did like nine or ten back in l.a wow and
i decided to stop that's where it like
started right too yeah yeah well no
that's sick the rumor is it started with
two guys like talking [ __ ] in the
parking lot and they were about to get
into a fight and they said instead
give me a week
and we'll both take a week and write the
worst things we can say about each other
and settle it that way and the winner
wins the fight so to speak
cheers yeah comedians aren't a real
physical fighting bunch
yeah not really it's more psychological
yeah
did you guys ever get in a fight as a
kid
yeah
i have
one guy
was kicking my balls and i was swinging
my little bible at him
i was at church
and i was like really good at church
so i had like a little bible case
i put my bible in a little knapsack
what'd you roll
nine
uh
he
why was he doing that just to be a dick
where was that he was kind of annoying i
don't know why it was my fault
so i think dylan had the highest nine i
had six what'd you have cream i have
three you are high
i had three no i didn't know koreans
went to church that's crazy
on do you want the yes please
oh it's right there
and the lighters there
have you gone on fight dylan
um
i've done this we used to play this game
called bodies in high school
and it was how many how many bodies you
have
what's your body my uh
i was pretty good at fighting but i
accidentally
uh throat punched somebody and that uh
foul yeah that was not supposed to throw
punch people no it's a below the neck
above the waist sort of situation below
the neck above the weight oh between the
just like
what was this like junior league no this
was just like us being like bored
you know
no yeah
so you throw a punch someone and you
were so traumatized you never punched
anyone again
well
like
uh what happened when i i [ __ ] him up
actually bad and that
you didn't feel good you were a
heavyweight
yeah
still are so you're just fake but you're
fighting for fun
and you actually actually hurt someone
yeah his throat yeah what was wrong with
his throat well i punched him as hard as
i could trying to hit him in the chest
and it hit his throat and he yeah went
down and he was like i'm stuck into this
yeah who's is that it was an ugly cry
and everything is it me or you it's just
it's mine all right clockwise
i don't know what way they go palestine
and then i did it again
in college years later when i was all
fit just to prove a point
wait you beat the show somebody yeah so
like you're two and oh in fights
yeah yeah but only two fights i don't
know well wait the point you're trying
to make what was that yeah
him and i were just really competitive
and he was a wrestler and he said
throughout high school and he said that
just because i was like working out it
wouldn't mean that
that he would like smoke me in a fight
and he made a whole thing of it our
friends and there was money involved and
so i kicked the [ __ ] out of them
literally or yeah with your punches what
kind of fight with my punches the thing
that took him down was i got him in the
gut once and he ran out of air oh he
fell and got shot
so it's like boxing headshots why didn't
he try to wrestle you
well
it was like a mix of both but it was mma
yeah i got them both like they were just
like we'll do anything i was i was
pretty fit back then so i was training
to be a boxer actually
i got injured yeah so it's not just
strength you are all actually you you
actually were doing yes i had a i had a
a boxer i had a trainer who was a boxer
for how long
maybe like eight months but before then
i was pretty fit like i was going to the
gym at least like once twice a day did
you play sports in high school
yes i played football and then i
wrestled my freshman year
where'd you go to college
i went to
a film school in chicago because it was
the only thing i could get into
and i just wanted to go far away
far away fly away
and then i went to film school wait so
they had a film that's where i learned
of wrestling pretentious people
huh at film school they had a wrestling
team
no that was in high school my freshman
year of high school oh that so that's
when you fought again
yeah i fought in college i decided to
stop being a fat kid and i got i lost
over a hundred pounds
got a boxing trainer oh he he wrestled
in high school my bad correct yes yeah
getting my stories twisted what was your
first fight like
um
i fought this guy for money he was uh he
was smaller than me i was a wrestler and
he beat the [ __ ] out of me i like
blacked out a bunch of times he was like
135 pounds
and yeah it was bad
and then he was the problem how did you
lose the problem was i was a wrestler so
i was leaning over and he was just
hitting me with an uppercut
and like i got i got to the fight i was
it was at the local county was he a
boxer he was a juvenile delinquent he uh
is black
no we only had one of those he
sounds bad we uh
we
we decided to fight and he he was uh he
like broke windows out of cars and stuff
so he was used to punching pale things
yes so where did the money come in it
was like 20 bucks
he challenged you or you no my buddies
my buddy spotted me he's like you got
this
but it was also his cousin so maybe he
set me up
but then the other time we fought we had
a whole ufc bracket that we decided to
do kind of like you like you just fight
because it's fun
but then i
broke a guy's nose and he was bleeding
everywhere and then the fight ended did
it make you feel bad
i pretended to feel bad
right
yeah
that's real yeah
no i felt bad
after the fact
yes
why are we all where
what about your second fight
that that might say that was my second
fight i broke the guy's nose what was
your first one
the guy yeah the delinquent so who was
the fight for the second guy
the second guy he was a he's like 240
that was a ufc fight
um we had ufc gloves on for that one the
first one we were just bare knuckles
bare knuckles is way worse yeah you
cannot take a punch no it's
painful
yeah if you have bought like i realize
with boxing gloves you can take a lot
more punches so like that's why it lasts
so long
which is probably worse for brain damage
right
maybe
i didn't think about where i placed them
at all
what do you think
you have a lot of
map to move around correct
can i get one of those odds
yeah for sure sweet
i'll get the lighter
so what do you think about
trump uh having his house raided by the
fbi
what was that rated for
for having classified documents after
his presidency
huh
well
is the fbi pro or anti-trump or are they
just doing that well merrick garland was
appointed by trump who's that he's the
head of the fbi whoa
and he said conflict of interest
i think it was a matter of national
security well then no one's above that
because yeah you know
what do you think
i think it's like
so symbolic like these republicans don't
want to take
any humiliation
they're already so triggered they're all
it's like so symbolic ironically right
yeah yeah
they're they feel like they're on the
ropes or something
the abortion is illegal like they should
be happy
and i am
rich
oh rich just looking over those fields
of cows
knowing that the world's right
[Laughter]
no i don't know that is it is crazy i'm
sure it is a sense of calm
[Laughter]
2016.
i don't know did they say what type of
documents trump apparently had
they said something about nuclear
something or other
oh then that's pretty important
then yeah sure
i think like what was he gonna do with
him like what's the plan
it's gonna be released
week by week in small segments
queueing on
i thought he had the jfk papers
i think every president gets to see that
that would be a kind of a cool thing
it's just like what do you do if you're
the president
and then you get to see like what
happened to jfk are there aliens
what's going on
do you think those the presidents
actually learned that information
no because i think trump would have told
us uh no i don't think so because i
don't think anyone can keep a secret
that good
well
isn't it like
under the uh under the radar like you'll
die if you tell anyone this
that's why they killed canada yeah i
mean like there are forces more powerful
than presidents right
yeah god replace your second settlement
pick up your second settlements okay
who put down for who's going first
dylan oh nice
good job it's gonna be great
okay
what would you do
what about trump
no no no uh if you found out
about
so you found if there was aliens but
you'd you wouldn't care that much about
your own life
you'd have to you'd have to have your
family threatened
because yeah
as a man i mean just like the worst
imaginable if
if there were
an agency more powerful than any
president i'm sure their tactics are
pretty
good
you know
oh it's my turn right roll yep ready to
get going
katan game
i got a five
what do you think
hans do you think there's do you think
there's anybody more powerful than the
president
yeah of the united states of america
yeah
a single a single person
named lady gaga
lebron james
oh there we go
physically yes
felicity jones mm-hmm
i don't think there's a single person
more powerful unless i mean i guess
there probably would be right but like
that person doesn't want to be shouldn't
we have democracy and no person should
be that much more powerful than the rest
maybe
but what if they're like vetted to be
the
most morally conscious of the like what
if they why would that
maybe to make decisions that humans
can't be trusted or are political but
they're human they're not better than us
maybe
but maybe a few are
you guys watching anyone is that much
better did you watch that show the boys
then they're present did you ever hear
that show the boys yes it was a great
show yeah the like superhero people and
like corporation like that's
that's the future pond you've watched
the boys yeah
yeah but they're like similar to like
how people in the environment like
celebrities
so they pay these millions of contracts
but they superheroes with super powers
and they always kill people and they
watch like every episode right like
purposefully or accidentally
and but but seriously
and then they they have like pr teams to
work with people when they [ __ ] up and
like all these like media systems come
in and influence the six so it's like
it's like the nfl and oj
sure yeah
yeah no for real
but it's a
they were going into neighborhoods and
injecting little kids with this super
drug
we just killed all of this it got pulled
again
well it got pegged on that and uh yeah
they were like what did you really want
four you roll the sex
and you rolled the six yeah okay
what'd you get uh ridge four four
anybody one we we're both on that one we
don't we
would or
10 10.
okay uh
does anyone need a
a wood pack is killing no how much wood
would a
wood yeah i need one you want to lay
down do you have a wheat or sheep lay
down sideways
yes you might have to borrow your neck
grace hans
uh do you have a brick
i don't uh
okay
you can do we can do one for one this
time
that's too kind you're too kind well
it's all a ploy
he's like i'm gonna take advantage of
you
somebody has a joke about a ploy seven
seven move that robber oh was that the
ploy um
seven
hans would you be so kind to move the
robber to the nine we're still taking
internships what's your favorite
character in in the boys
i love uh
translucent i think he's hilarious this
one
yeah i'll take from you hans just
because no one's out there no i said the
other nine come on
come on now he's uh he's funny how he's
like in the girls room and stuff and
he's like hanging out he's invincible
yeah
invisible and no invincible like that
movie with mark wahlberg yeah who's
who's translucent
he's the he's the one that's invisible
what about the one funeral it's just an
empty casket like they're like i don't
remember that and they're doing scenes
of him famous but there's just nothing
there because i see like the posters
there's just nothing there
it's so cool because rich because they
make it all like
corporate like these people are famous
people but they can like [ __ ] up and
kill
people it's wild so it's like
the dallas mavericks that guy
if he just owns superheroes
what's his name mark cuban mark cuban
yeah it's just like mark cuban if he was
a superhero well it's more like walmart
or like halliburton or like
coca-cola
and then they bought like superheroes
yeah yeah that's such a good idea they
make a joke
so it's like russia whenever they make
people win the olympics and they choose
them up six
another one yeah jesus who's red
that's
someone else you're a little [ __ ] i'm
always red they do a bit where they're
on an airplane and they're like this is
the spirit delta united airlines like
like so it's very like it just bashes
like corporate america is it funny oh
it's
dude it's
i looked it up because each episode you
know the guy homeland
is like an actual [ __ ] oh duh
six i looked it up every episode's like
a movie right yeah and
the per
they had 11 million dollars per episode
budget so they had like [ __ ]
yeah exactly
per episode that's their budget the guy
that plays homelander was caught he's
from new zealand i think
the guy from homeland the from the guy
from the boys homelander was caught
like trying to fight fight this like 18
year old kid
really yeah the actors like in real life
yeah but he's an [ __ ] in the show
he's
he's white and privileged now i'm
kidding do you think he's like maybe
like really
like an [ __ ] in real life and like
that's why they hired him because he's
so good at it oh yeah
christian bale
he's like oh i wasn't putting anything
on that last
take and like no it's great
you're such an [ __ ] i think people
[ __ ] realize christian bale hans kim
did you watch the whole thing no i
watched every episode
yeah it's [ __ ] amazing
and then the get the last episode
all spoiled i was gonna say this is all
sports
watching this and
and um
and what happened to the guy homelanders
dad what happened to homeland understand
anyone ever broke for a wood by the way
no
buddy
is that how it ended oh no you know how
it ends it ends with the kid
remember
yeah that was the last scene yeah
someone threw something at him and then
he just zaps him and then the crowd
cheers and shoots him in there so then
they're like oh violence is okay now
it's okay yep he didn't lose any q
rating points
eight can i have the water
i'm not on any [ __ ]
but yeah i think that movie's an
allegory
night which one
homeland or zoo zoolander or whatever
boys could you move the robber to eight
please
thank you hanzo which character do you
like can i take from you sir yes
i like
the hot one
the main character's girlfriend
oh yeah starlight
yeah do you know whose son the main i
like you know who do you know who it is
it's it's dennis quaid's son
jack wade oh
now how awesome is that randy quinn the
guy from no no it's dennis quit the guy
from a [ __ ] uh parent trap yes
oh nice and uh
what was
it's your turn yeah i know okay
um
[Music]
this should be like poker where they
have like the see-through table when you
put your cards down so then the audience
can see what you have in your hand
exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah oh he's
going on settlement
i don't have anything to trade you guys
are talking about movies i have not seen
none movies
do you did you see a lot of movie you
didn't see a lot of movies as a kid no
we watched uh do you ever hear the pink
panther yeah we watched that as a family
that was funny that's great it's a great
movie yeah it's that's that's the steve
martin one right yeah it's pretty much
my sense of humor that's it's uh ridge
how many cars yeah steve martin is
incredible
he is
he
is do you ever watch his specials he'll
just say [ __ ] right in the middle of it
like once yeah and it's just like it's
so hard yes but like he could have been
clean he's like everything else is clean
but he then he just says [ __ ]
like why
it's a while if you're ever feeling down
about comedy that's a good thing to
watch it's just like you would have
breaker would
let me give you a sheep
give me a two for one i'll give you a
one i don't have two for would you roll
hans give me a shoot for something else
what do you need hans
wood or ish brick
okay fine thanks for what
just to keep the game moving
trying to keep the game moving we're at
three victory points just for the
integrity of the game there's seven
people watching this you have a really
good voice that's true you have the best
voice
cons think so too
do you think so pink panther
no the voice i don't give a [ __ ] about
his voice
he just said you said he had the best
voice so false fact check
sorry we can edit over this i'm like cnn
we'll fix it and post it
action
so nancy polotna
so dude i was hoping they'd shoot her
down i was like i hope shoot her down
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i thought maybe they
would
i was watching the live stream of her
airplane
i was on that flight tracker thing you
know
i was like if it just stops moving she's
done
it didn't it it's your turn i just think
like you're somewhere in the world
looking with the flight tracker yeah i'm
guessing what and it's closing yeah your
roll oh
nine
a stickler for specific rules and i
respect that about you because that is
the game i do like that
that is catan that is good life is a
series of rules yeah yeah oh man
you done [ __ ] me up huh how you doing
anything is how you do everything break
break
no one has a brick
especially hans being from north korea
me being from new jersey
kareem is from palestine
texas west bank texas
house and texas no no no no i live by
the wells fargo another night it's from
the gaza strip
we had a west bank in my town
they called a strip like oh that sounds
nice no yeah i know it's an actual bank
you can get money from it
eight
[ __ ] i'm always on eight i just get mad
every time somebody rolls and hauntly
leans forward
it's almost every turn i know it's just
it's it's literally
so comfortably too does anyone have a
wheat for a wood
uh yeah i got wheat for wood all right
let's do it sold
my man
that's rich all right let's
development card han's your turn can you
believe that uh
me a jewish person trading with a
palestine
i thought you said you're italian you're
jewish i'm italian italian jewish oh
that's
german jew that would be contradicting
um
but whenever there's a jewish person
that brings me up on stage they're like
oh
you're jewish hershberger because it's
kind of like a jewish name
and i'm like yeah i'm german
or the people that killed your people
yeah i feel bad
you're the people that try to copy us
and that's why you made names that sound
like ours but we switched it up on you
but then i try to explain them there
used to be
like there was jewish people in germany
yeah we know
then the holocaust happened
and then they were all like i'm getting
bad vibes
imagine getting it vibes are super low
getting like a fast pass
oh my god
roll up with a handicapped kid
they're like
you could skip the line
that's horrible
that's terrible it's not funny who wants
wood yeah we could edit this all out
wait
we'll fix it
just say that for everything yeah
this is my goodness say the worst things
live we'll fix it on fuzz one of us gets
nothing one of us gets snl they're like
did you play katana in 2022 on august
14th
yeah do you have a how many are you
doing
i have no cards interesting
wait what'd you guys roll [ __ ]
nine a lot of nines
did you does hans did you just roll a
nine yes
okay
i thought katan should have their own
strain
wheat yes i gotta pay attention dude i
don't want it
no
what would i take it for a brick
oh god
[Laughter]
oh this is fun we're having a good time
[ __ ] eight just hands
i know there's so many just [ __ ] i
usually always do eight too you gotta
have anybody have a brick
where is the other eight
it's covered up
i feel like that robber's been there for
a minute yeah you know i don't have this
is going to change everything i can't
get through this i could have got rid of
it damn it i should have got rid of it
oh yeah
yeah yeah
i don't have a night but i could have
bought a card and probably got it
that would have been a smart choice on
my part you all done yeah i haven't been
paying attention enough
six
so teddy graham
the scholar
eight is that what it was
uh no six i'm gonna play a night card
too oh nice nice nice i like that uh
i'm gonna move it to the nine right
behind it
please what year do you think this is uh
representing
fourteen hundred times i'll take from
you the dark ages fourteen hundreds do
you know that for a fact no it was a
simpler time yeah because like hundreds
because the night everything else is
like it could have been any time but
then the night puts it in like the dark
ages
after the roman 11 fell
the romans
the night
would you roll 11 yeah
i have watched the dark knight we can
talk about that
that movie is amazing
yeah wait is there a medieval times in
austin hey
was it another eight wait wait wait wait
wait wait
i'll trade you
for that brick
no thanks all right
go ahead
four
let's go
uh he's just picking up every roll
it's crazy yeah does anyone have any
brick brother i'm so so rigged
hans khan 2022. there's like the brick
is hard to come by
that's true
hans gate 2022
did he or did he not
put too many weak cards down
all right i'm gonna try this for brick
you tell me
do you think
here comes a controversial something
it's a hot take
do you think that maybe we don't need to
you know police the blacks so much
less police
yeah in
in nine neighborhoods
is that what you're saying
i'm saying
maybe we could instead of getting less
police we could get more
i rolled the nine food stamps
and
don't have a knife
yeah i see where you're going with this
it's yeah it's genius
it's literally like why not think of
that
[ __ ]
that's where you you articulated it too
put that in a good idea
that we're definitely keeping in yeah
we're gonna repeat that actually
whatever we have to do
it's not on shuffle it's on repeat
what do you think coz
i think let's do it let's figure it out
less police
in um i think
from the hoa
most of the police forces in new york
and
l.a
dude the east coast is so bad with cops
though it's [ __ ] a lot of the cops
are just
occupying air force
meant to
in texas in california i don't think
they have police i don't think i've ever
seen a police officer
in california or texas
really
what did i roll
four
what did you roll
four baby
yeah you
you wanted because you have your four is
everywhere for you are you sure you've
rolled it
i already picked it up
another nine whoever's on this is crazy
folks i mean if you're watching live
right now this is a doozy the robber is
constantly picking up it's
hans i'm starting to think
that you're trying to win this game
that's my goal
another eight
holy [ __ ]
where's the other eight
there's
four
that's it just fours and eights and
sixes
and fives and and other nines and you
know all the numbers
but another four oh i gotta wait
hell yeah
there we go
she uh sheep for wood
going once
going
all right yeah i'll do it
you'll do it okay oh [ __ ] was that where
do you want it from yeah
[Laughter]
all right
for the sake of it
[Laughter]
it was a wash
i appreciate it though you guys both did
it immediately
hold on wait
i took my brain a second to catch up
oh wait that's not really
10.
i still get that feeling hans is trying
to win
it's very suspicious
it gives you that impression
i'm just glad he doesn't have any no
development cards the odd thing is you
kept on building more settlements
he's all out of hiring more people than
one percent yeah it's like the one
person he's a one percenter
[Laughter]
is this a joke
does anyone want three for either of
these
hans gate 2020
what are you trying investigate hans you
need an ore yeah i'll do that where was
hans on august
15th 2020. you have trees and sheep can
i have a sheep
what the [ __ ] is going on
are these legal traits
are they legally trading you guys are
playing communism right now yeah hans
come on this is is this legal
this is an open air market this is how
the slave trades used to go dude just
like that
who's rolling i bet you it'll be in an
eight
or a nine
no this time at nine come on dylan show
us the nine don't worry guys this time
i'm gonna get two
nine
oh my god
dude nine this big come on
at least we know satan's playing with us
now literally so crazy that the yeah i'm
about to roll what do you all think it's
gonna be it's so crazy about that five
and four maybe if we wish for it to be
like a nine
satan you're real if this is a nine it's
so crazy that that robber has been on
that nine this whole time
eight hey
close enough it's a hans number though
investigate hans 2019
where was hans on september 10th
20th your mother's [ __ ]
living there
free does anyone have a stone for a wood
he's put his stakes in the ground can i
yeah
for wood yes let's do it no no no no i
can't i'm good you're good
it's my mom
my mom's in chicago the other day was my
brother and she boasted a picture of
both of their feet in the water
i'm like why are you posting free feet
pics ma
what was that 10 10
10. let's go
where's the chicken palm
maybe that's like
the moms are just like
like netflix like they'll get a whole
group going
and monetize
yeah i agree
wait what how's the subscriber get the
subscribers there's another customer
free trial periods yeah and then when
everyone's in
they're tr you're get you're having to
pay thirty dollars a month for mom and
foot picks what size feet
seven
we're out of stock [ __ ] we need more
seven foot
yeah sorry bethany your feet are two we
need more seven footers
your feet are too big and your feet are
too small
but these feet are just right
to be honest seven that's we'll scout
the nail salons and hey what do you do
for 11.
you want to be famous
do you think they write off pedicures if
you sell feed pics you got that's a it's
your business that is
like
no you probably could right like it's
that's a tax write-off right hans
where were you on
what
i agree
uh rock
or rock
or
got some wood for sale
no i think seven's a good a good sized
foot because then you don't fall over as
easy either
if your feet are too seven oh if your
feet are too speaking of sevens
count them up oh six even
well you're supposed to use your feet
like hands when you're walking how many
cars you got
easier
we put our feet into little shoes and
they put they pad the heel out so
everyone's just so we're we're [ __ ]
saying let them know with the heel of
our foot like this
no shut the [ __ ] up and listen dude
i'm telling people about feet are you
not listening
kareem you're so annoying you just like
don't listen you just interrupt all the
time
what'd you say
positive it's hard to get a good cadence
those are new glasses
thanks man
i like them you can't even tell they're
on your face really
why is that funny because i don't
believe you
no i'm
being serious
you used to have black ones
yeah
i don't have those anymore my little
niece she wears glasses like that
nice yeah kids have weird glasses they
like to experiment
they don't even do anything oh dylan's
got uh
four now
or now i lied
ridge got four
no i have three
han says five oh really
it's five yeah scores
four
okay
we're in action
or
oh no
so do you think that fapia is like
going well
what are you listening or were you
saying here you go the the fifa
yeah what's up
fapia
first funniest person in austin did you
sign up are you
oh sending this one out
what's that
tart starter says i'm tripping balls on
shrooms right now
he's straight he's
i roll the watching
who's your top five funniest people in
austin not including yourself dylan
sullivan because you're number one rich
hershberger nice
where's kareem yagnam in this last top
80. that's it i can't think of any
others
i think uh joe rogan he's pretty funny
um i feel like i've heard of this guy
ron white um
tony hinchcliffe tom sakura thompson oh
i forgot yeah thomas lowkey austin
christina p yeah that's it that's five
yeah
that'd be funny if somebody came out
with a list and they just put all those
people in it
really yeah
so sad
[Music]
that just [ __ ] me up
and you've got two night cards
so you're basically at seven
so he needs three points to win
we're all just tied up i think for a
second i think everyone had three
we should no no hans has five now [ __ ]
no he has more than five it's a good
game to be a foreign
because you got a night card one night
card to get largest army
eight
this game is
just
the rich keep getting ready
i love settling
love cup being the colonizer
it's better to be the colonizer than
colonize
clifford
clifford the red red big dog
famous clifford quote
recognize it anywhere
i only have six points
only
what is your raw ridge
eight ah yeah
seven you know rum fell right hans or
something like that rome fell in a day
i don't think it actually fell in a day
technically it was still around till
like the 1100s
some say it's still around
some historians surmise that it might
still exist
so technically it never fell
some say it's still standing
there's historians watching this just
losing their [ __ ]
carlos losing his mind right now
just disrespecting their lives hey does
anyone have a freaking tree yes i got a
i got a freaking treat
yeah
i'll take it why
do you actually need sheep no
why did you do that
you ruined the sanctity of the game and
i got super war for anyone who's i'll
take me i'll say glory you're gonna win
yeah yeah yeah yeah i actually need this
i do need that
i don't need the sheep all right well
look who's good in the house
good job you gave him a house
it's over for you
why did you do that
just helping out a friend are there
friends in katan hans i gotta a dude
this is game over for you [ __ ]
because there's gonna be 38s
good job reg
sex that's pretty much your house
sex
yeah i should get point one of sex
that's funny tight
is anybody close to getting longest run
no not really
you done it's uh it's been a rough go
around yes you're up hans
seven
just
oh no settlement
no that was from my last turn oh
just knows already he just wait just now
he just knew
i hope you like trees
if you don't know no you know who wants
brick me we take some no you guys it's
it's gonna be game over
thanks oh
kareem is great
he made you feel bad about your trades
so that you'd feel less bad about his
and he's a little lead
i feel like i was just exploited
seven
oh
wait double one thing at a time
yeah oh there's already a seven so
wait so the robber first
does that mean he has to do it move it
twice hans or no that's road building
oh
what are you
oh [ __ ] you're right
it's a tough game i'm losing a lot of
sponsors
just by the minute
does anybody have brick
i'll give a lot
break breakdown
[Music]
five
i'm good
isn't it kind of crazy it takes this
much equipment to get good audio
yeah the audio is such a big part of it
oh man you guys are welcome
just hooking up
just hooking the boys up
hope you guys
hope you
i
guys
like
build two roads
dude everyone knows how to play the game
it's going really smooth so it's so nice
paul's in here
sorry paul he just caught a stray
i gotta leave with my integrity
but he got whataburger
sounds great another four folks
i'll trade for the brick i pity the fool
wait
have you guys been on hansa's dating
show
yet
you didn't yes me how your experience
was it was good it was good
oh yeah you were i guess
was this tonight or just like in the
past just in the past yeah
you should check it out sundays were you
a feature or were you like the date i
was a day person yeah but multiple dates
there nothing became though
han's just trying to make love happen
yeah he's a samaritan one sunday at a
time yeah
we need to gamify dating because
millennials are too autistic
okay sharks
[Laughter]
the problem autistic millennials
this is the solution
[Laughter]
let's get these nerds [ __ ]
two wood for brick
wait to eat
i'll do that to eat yeah
sweet
okay let's check in with our ridge
[Laughter]
rich how are you feeling about this game
today uh the second game's not going as
well i did not i i'm not happy with
where i placed my first settlement
rage why don't you look into the camera
and give a message to your fans
uh
2024
trump
okay no one no one's laughing because we
think you're serious
i am
okay let's go brandon
let's go brandon
let's go brandon
do you believe in dark brandon
what is dark brendan
he's like normal brandon
but he wants to destroy the suburbs
and collect them at seven oh [ __ ] all
right the mining industry
where are you moving it
i have a night if you move it on me i'm
just going to move it on you
i don't know if that's necessarily true
i have a night
if he if he plays that night he's
probably he's really close to winning
two two four six nine nine he's at nine
nine points
easy yeah
and there's nothing we can do about it
really
that sounds so good pretty much raping
you guys yeah because like the longest
road you can get that
largest army is hard
can you trade development cards
no
[Laughter]
which one was it it was a
that was a brick
one
i got so many of those
only person
i'm not doing great who's who's in
second place even are we all tied
no dylan sullivan is four five
i have four too
oh [ __ ]
building a road
i'll trade ponds europe two wood for a
rock
uh
you can still play it
wait was that was that a four under
there no yeah oh it is
oh
he you got taken up
took him
that sounds like a lord of the rings
character liam neeson's i took it
[Laughter]
i don't got tooken
he's got damn
who took you who took your hands it's
just these goddamn [ __ ] slabs
it's the southern
version of
taken
it's just theomond i got taken mom this
is liam decent
my they took me somewhere
why was that the best joke of the day
i think we're about three hours in
aren't we
nice just begun
oh no hans
he's so close to longest road
collusion
one more point investigate hans gate
where's my largest army
right here
is that it you done incredible y'all
then you're all finished
12. is anyone on 12. um
it doesn't matter
this hurdle around this 12.
you know what the most uh humiliating
part about katana is
i think we all know what
it's it's the
charade you put on when you know someone
is going to win
you mean faking it yeah
no no you go ahead yeah like people will
like pass it on and begin and be like
yeah go [ __ ] yourself with that and then
they'll when they're they know they're
gonna lose they pass the dice like
they don't want to fast
yeah 100
hey dylan you want two wood
sure why not
no keep the brick you need to make two
roads okay
i'll give you a wheat
[Laughter]
you want some sheep
[Laughter]
nobody's gonna understand that one
yeah for the podcast listeners
[Laughter]
you gotta watch the youtube for that one
do you post this on spotify or anything
instant replay uh maybe i'll try
do you do you have that do you like pod
beam
[Laughter]
do you have the pod beam
i'll take my participation longest road
plaque please
let's go
it is pretty much a play yeah yeah
not even according to the participation
of a trophy of this game
i'm still inevitably going to win even
after that move there should be a
championship trophy and you have to
carry four you see what i mean
what a
useless move
for long in the inevitable hope i get on
that
did you count your seven cards did you
count seven oh damn it
damn i was hoping you weren't diligent
that's his last name ron's diligent
kim
dillinger
you are really you are a very diligent
person very very different
the jokes are
so dumb
oh
no it's just more insulting honestly
nice
dylan joanna breck
sure
i gotta wheat
oh i should have thought of that out
better oh well
trades are still open ridge and i have
nothing to lose greatest comedian in
texas
wow
these people know their stuff yeah
thanks for reading it out loud
did epstein really hang himself what do
you guys think let us know
i think he hung himself
[Laughter]
from the creators of tooken
[Music]
[Laughter]
it is 3 in the morning central time in
case anybody was wondering we have some
people from new zealand it's 8 a.m
over there
guten tag
four
another four
dude i'm racking them
oh no hans is going to win this round
all right inevitable demise
it's almost upon us
hold on hold on no hold on
what do you need
do you have a way to pull out of this
okay
because what i'm going to see the
longest road from dylan that doesn't
do anything they're just they're just
shaking the jar of ants
give me that
oh no he's playing something
no
what
that's the game yeah that's the game
wait i still have to remove the robber
also monopoly monopoly yeah yes
oh i'm so glad i don't have yeah i don't
have anything either
i live too rock now
oh nice he needs three
i use my wheat pork
[ __ ] and i build this city
and you guys can all go [ __ ] yourself
typical americans
and though i wish i knew how to use the
numbers
damn it
again
there again
good game good game sir so what do you
think
how was the creek today
creek was fun
it had a really fun energy throughout it
was a packed crowd what were you yeah
it's a pack the crowd i was on a uh
gay competition show
and then
they're just it was awarded most gay
really yeah i got a hundred bucks i'm
not even that gay
you gotta ride through town
that's what you know wait is this before
is this before your er i mean is this
after your showhands yeah they have this
gay competition yeah yeah
and after the gay competition they have
an open mind
a banana phone yeah yeah
which is actually more gay yeah i'm
afraid i'm afraid to do that one don't
be for obvious reasons what do you think
hans why because you're afraid there
might be jews in the audience no at a
comedy club no
no way
what do they say about you guys i
couldn't think of one mean thing to say
about you guys yeah i don't get it
either yeah
i would just say
like
no hans has great roasts but they're
like they make you want a quick coffee
they're like hey you're not actually why
does your parents hate you
stop doing almost jealousy [ __ ]
yeah try to strike for the core
straight for the heart and the head will
follow they're not even funny they're
just awful big
a lot of quotes from that from that dog
strike for the heart
he's a big red dog
with a spot for tactical revenge
clifford
[Laughter]
dude that dog was huge yeah
yeah they drew it in my house this dog
imagine his [ __ ] maybe everyone else is
really small instead of like you know
they have those little bags
you know those little bags you pick up
[ __ ] with they just had to use a garbage
bag
yeah just throw it away
they got a tarp
they could he could fertilize the whole
garden
nice
they they just hire them out they're
like
hey here yeah
grow the biggest tomatoes you know dogs
eat baby poops they're puppies poops
because if a predator sees a little baby
poop
it starts getting horny
what kind of predator
like a cougar a cougar or like yeah they
start looking around they're like oh
there's a baby so like mama dogs they're
like trained like when they're like
when they're done shoving babies out
their vagina like trigger something in
them to eat baby poop
i've seen my dog eat baby dog like the
mom incredible mom eat the babies
way to go mom yeah for real no i just
really like baby poop
wait can cook protecting my kids can
cougars breed with dogs
uh can i find out i got nipples greg
it's like a mule
so haunted cougar
dogs you're on kill tony tomorrow
was like have you ever been to joe
rogan's house
yeah once like i feel like that'd be
cool it's too personal man is it i feel
like you guys are hungry anyways
what do you think about him
i love him
i hate that piece of [ __ ]
does tony have like a special guest if
he just if he's not hosting it will he
have like no someone running or does it
not happen he did one episode to kill
jeremiah just to prove that to jeremiah
that
this is a true story he can't run it
yeah
it was like did it suck yeah
jeremiah would just let them do their
weird improv exercises in front of
everybody and then he was like 60
seconds all right next comedian so they
got like 15 comedians yeah and then tony
was like oh yeah i wonder why tony did
the other way maybe it's because if you
don't interview them then the show just
becomes about them and it never becomes
about the people on the show it's just
like a bunch of right it's like
basically an open mic then it's just
showing random randomized people not
like the people that are actually on it
so like it's good to have a long
interview because it makes it about the
people that are on the show that are the
professionals you find the interesting
parts
to roast about them yeah
definitely and jeremiah was like you're
spending too long on each comedian we
need to
go to the next one
do uh
i don't know
i'm gonna ask about writing have you
been writing new minutes i've just been
writing in general
just feeling the general anxiety been
like [ __ ]
this written in a while and you do like
more topical stuff now
yeah
but it hits hard
whatever i can do to get a laugh
[Laughter]
what happened to all the strippers
we started we moved on from that we
became more advanced and more
intellectual
we like brains more than tits
yeah
sexy
i liked the show whenever it was uh
i like it still
i think it teaches people how to write
jokes
what do you think dylan
have you been on kill tonight i hate
comedy dude
do you make a living off it
not all the way yet i'm getting closer
because like
like i think about the people like at
our level and i'm like who's making it
enough i also don't apply myself enough
i think i could if i was uh resourceful
yeah but that's a problem with being a
creative
you're not as resourceful you're just
more creative yeah i'm very going to get
sucked into like a terrible contract
that i don't read
one day
and just like be you know
why don't you just start reading
contracts right now just to get a feel
for it well i did i took entertainment
law or entertainment law class oh and
but it's not even about knowing it's
just like wow this document's like eight
pages
and then they're like oh [ __ ] and now
they can they know when i brush my teeth
you know
so you didn't really learn that much
from it no or didn't apply it anyway
well yeah i mean not that i've been
given eight
contracts but like one time they did
like there was a youtube thing the
youtuber invited us all to like
be on her youtube video and they had
contracts
and it was like
four or five paragraphs
i was like that's probably fine
you're like one two three four
wow this is a real contract that's less
than 10 paragraphs oh yeah put my
old john hancock on the bottom and then
i don't think about it it's hard to hide
evil in four-pack yeah you need at least
seven paragraphs yeah
you gotta watch out for those middle
paragraphs though
or like or like
or like two through four middle upper
in within that pair and within a middle
paragraph or like
oh yeah
top
bottom of the top
upper middle middle
upper middle by no lower middle yeah
totally i heard the raising the taxes on
them yeah i know it's exhausting can you
pull the light switch
you got it
there we go we just had to do that
because the glare on the katan board was
brutal
yeah they couldn't see what was going on
is there a katan influencers
influencers do they do a twitch
situation i feel like that'd be pretty
fun
yeah they should i'm sure they have i'm
just starting the trend now right you
got the yeah i don't know how well you
can see it but i do point this camera at
it no yeah i'd see it thursday it's a
great setup i think it's great we need
an intern to do the board movements yeah
um
i think you could become that could be
your niche
board games do you have a true do you
have a word
yeah
well
do you have twelve hundred dollars in a
catan board
but luckily for you you get to watch us
all play this
honda's master class of katan no
do this this game would be brutal if we
paid for money played with the money
hans would be rich though
yeah
so tonight the games went uh i would
take a cut you had really got to pay the
house really good placement
um
yeah i did i had i put it right here
yeah
yeah that was good yeah and then ridge
placed it
uh here and here i think correct
and you beat me to that the 1199 yeah
because that's what i was going for here
was good because my choice was either
here or here and if i go either of these
places these are the same wood rock and
sheep so then i would have had to find
brick and wheat which isn't really
together that much
like there's this i think this was still
available that's a two is is there have
you looked up is there something about
placing
on this row
around the edge is better than placing
in here because i feel like if you place
in here you get stuck
with four people
sometimes it depends yeah it depends on
who puts one yeah it depends on what
numbers are valuable i think hans failed
to mention that all of his [ __ ]
numbers hit
thousands of times nine hit a four eight
nine hit like that was also like uh
to mention that no i put this here
because i knew i only needed bricks yeah
we'll go back to the footage and see how
much
i'm gonna study that [ __ ] after oh yeah
you think i'm going to bed tonight
what time do you normally go to bed
uh late
like morning i think you're like known
as the latest
person to stay up in austin comedy i
thought it was the gay thing yeah well
that's when i do all my gay crime
that was the fat thing
same thing oh dylan the guy that stays
up really late
yeah you know
6 7 a.m
you know he does a lot of crime right
he just sits outside of vadegas yeah
that
that french bakery was wiped clean he
scares those
blonde women again
well that's my superpower i can scare
women
they just think you're friendly and
you're like
yeah
well their fault for being afraid of
ghosts
i have a ghost mask one more show what
do you guys do for crime crime yeah
mostly drink and drive
what do you do
all of ridges are really like
trump 2024 drunk driving sending the end
of the new year
he's a real genuine guy yeah
you can't be mad at it i'm just i
learned from the best just honestly
he's just honest all the time man drunk
driving is great no
it's good for the economy that's what
people don't talk about yeah it keeps
the police out there
we need more of them
it helps the community
guys have you played this game secret
hitler
no
oh that's a good game have you played a
mafia
no it's that
uh
a werewolf
it's the same thing you get assigned a
role and one person is a mafia and we
all oh yes it's like the modern clue if
you will yeah i think so it's all these
bodies bodies pete davidson
i don't get the reference that's the
same why is it still on me
it's the ridge hershberger cam
ridge hershberger the fans asked for it
and we we gave it to him all right uh
well i don't know what to do with my
hands
hans you can tell you're making it now
because you got a nice haircut so yeah
when did you got it in phoenix tony was
like great we're filming a special and
you look the bodyguard has a better
haircut
i love that tony that sounds about right
mean funny way
and then i go right downstairs to my
hotel room and then there's a barber
shop right there that is nice good job
to be honest bodyguards do have good
haircuts yeah they care about what do
they look like because if you have a
shitty haircut and you're trying to be a
bodyguard nobody's going to listen to
you seriously yeah
that'd be a funny sketch just like a
bodyguard with like relationships
he's just got long hair like yonder i
seriously get behind the tape
here's something for real guys
you should totally do that hey was i
mean to that guy
here's some accidents
our security guards have good haircuts
pants we got the real character
oh man
all right should we call it
i think 40 more minutes
it's like we should do this in the
daytime maybe when i move to north
campus
it'll be more accessible
we could have more are you taking these
sick ass couches with you no will you uh
have parking
yeah nice
probably i mean austin has good parking
i know it's pretty easy to park here
yeah
i started parking in handicap spots
oh my god
yeah the cops here really don't do
anything don't check anything
there aren't any that's what i just i've
been speeding up and running around
dude i got hit by a car the other week
and i called the police and i was like
hey i just gotta hit my car i don't know
if i had to do this for like insurance
or whatever
no like are you hurt and i'm like no
like
yeah then we're not coming out oh what
did you call about like what do you want
yeah i know she literally she was like
annoyed for sure
hit by a car oh yeah
the police
we really don't need that we can pick
from the hoa
well i've never like been pulled over in
texas either
yeah is that is it possible i mean i
don't
i always feel like i'm in trouble when a
door squeaks open
you guys aren't supposed to be here
we need better lighting i got i got hit
by a car two days ago
but i mean i didn't get it
i love it
i i went into target and i walked out
and there's like a huge traffic jam and
everyone was like watching me walk out i
walked to my car my front left uh my
driver's door got hit and they're like
dude that guy just hit your car and it
like wasn't that bad and my car's a
piece of [ __ ]
and they're like you're gonna so i went
and talked to him my door was like it's
all right man it's good
and i was like that's a christian thing
to do right you're not supposed to suit
your neighbor let criminals get away
with crime
do you want to punch me too
i let drunk drivers go i know in the
name of god
i bless you
go christian soldier back to back home
you go do another shot wild
anytime
cheers
so
this is fun like do you guys like comedy
stuff no i do i do i do i don't really
know what it is hey what was okay this
is a lame question but i'd like to hear
everyone's response is uh
what was your first experience like
really loving comedy
like being amazed by it
if you remember
i uh when i first did it
so not before you
so not before you got on stage
being amazed at comedy
yeah uh listening to brian regan
you got logs
what was this a stand-up yeah his bed
about
he's amazing i
don't i don't understand it when i see
two logging trucks passing each other
like that could have been solved with a
phone call
you got logs
i got logs over here
is he just the poor man's uh jerry
seinfeld
um
i think jerry seinfeld's the poor man's
jason yeah he's kind of a dick he's got
a billion dollars
uh my my on a more serious note mine was
i watched joey diaz at the improv
coco diaz yeah dude he did an hour
there's like when was that
uh four or five years ago like this was
before the first comedian i'm sure you
were like that this is wild yeah dude i
don't remember a single joke he did but
i was dying the whole time and i was
like oh that's like a and he like rolled
the end the energy was just rolling yeah
and he i don't remember anything the
only thing i remember him saying was
he's talking about sticking a q-top
q-tip up his dick hole that's the only
thing but like it's just
the energy was crazy
wow
but
that seems like the worst thing to stick
up your dick hole because it's so dry
it's like
do you remember the boys they're like
crawling up people's dick holes did you
ever see them yeah
when they're doing the sex [ __ ] the hero
gasm
and they're doing the
yeah and then sneezes and inside
the boys yeah yes
he's like running for the exit yeah
yeah
he explodes up how about you kareem i i
was going to say uh do you guys remember
when they see the oddball comedy
festival back in the day that thing was
so
epic and chappelle did his first set
when he came back but louis did a set
and he was the only comic who actually
had a mic
who had a a wired mic so you could
actually hear him and i'll never forget
it this amphitheater is packed and he's
like what do you mean by he's the only
one like everyone had a wireless mic and
you could tell their sound was why
wasn't everyone else like hey can i get
a wired mic
i have no idea and he even made a point
to bring up like this is why he's wired
mike because you can [ __ ] hear me and
i was like oh this is why i love louie
because he headlined the thing but i
remember all cheering and he's like
you're all gonna die and like that was
just
uh the set was great it was one of the
first times i saw him and it was epic
i remember a louis bit he was like uh
we're all just living in a world of
people who haven't killed themselves yet
and i was like that's so dark anyways
uh that's the darkest darn thing i've
ever done heard cooking what about you
dylan
uh it was really
it was really two there's this guy
amazing jonathan who has a show in vegas
oh he's great yeah he died recently yeah
he did he had like a
cool documentary about him but he was
just really interesting and i remember
it being like
i didn't know people could say things
like that and do things like that
they're not allowed to do that there was
this amazing joke his opener had that
i'll never forget it's over it's this
old guy and dress up nice in his suit
like a frank sinatra sort of situation
and he pulls out this rope to cut it
because he's a magician so he starts
cutting the rope and talking and cutting
the rope shorter and talking and cutting
it shorter and then he just puts the
rope on the scissors on the table and
he's like so anyway
he's gonna do this trick
right like he's gonna like get the rope
together or do something crazy with it
and he's like and anyway and he just
totally dismisses it and i remember that
moment and then
the the other one was
probably also oh
when i moved to
so right after high school i moved to
chicago and i was checking out the
school and there was this improv true
there's this improv
called mike pizza because i couldn't do
anything in chicago because i wasn't 21
yet
so there's emperor
mike pizza and one of the sketches they
were
acting like women but one guy was
especially hilarious because he actually
acted like a woman like he didn't overdo
it
he just like acted like a person but he
he didn't even talk like it was just
like in the back of this real human not
like a woman
no like a real person like he wasn't
doing an impression of a woman it was
like
so subtle that it was [ __ ] hilarious
anything he did he didn't even need to
talk to like make people laugh and i
thought that was so
cool yeah that's a good note to like
just be a woman
yeah
that's the moral of that story
that's what i was getting at is he
transgender now probably i haven't
followed up with mike pizza lately
like pizza
italian [ __ ]
hey pepperoni guy
pepperoni my name is
michael pepperoni
i feel like you're very energetic on
stage and you do
what's up buddy
you're very animated
what time is it
uh
can you just walk behind the camera back
to the
back to the rope
that reminds me of like whenever you
have pants and they have that one string
and you just keep pulling it and it just
keeps coming you're like [ __ ] i gotta
cut it
then you cut it and it disappears it's
all right all right let's call it
good